foreign
[Music]
well hey what's going on yeah I got
distracted because you're because I kept
I heard it like over there too and I was
just like wait what's going on hey you
guys it's Friday night finally yep
end of the work week my favorite time of
the week
when I get home and I have a drink
and we hang out with you guys yep so
oracle's waving at us Hi how are you got
my new glasses today
see look for all of this time Tom was
trying to find these round gloves
because I have like a costume pair that
are like these and he really liked them
but they weren't reading glasses so I
could wear them and they looked cute and
everything but I couldn't see [__]
so we looked for a very long time like
looking for glasses that were just like
that but were reading glasses and we
finally found some finally found them
AliExpress AliExpress yeah it took like
a week or a week and a half to get here
but they finally got here today yeah
yeah so they weren't even that expensive
like 15 bucks no they weren't even that
I think they were 11 something
so I might get another pair yeah they
had a lot of stuff to choose from on
there too yeah I mean they're cute I
like them yeah I mean I don't know if
they're exactly exactly the same but
they're very very similar very close
they're very very similar if they're
over there somewhere no that's not them
yeah
they're all over there somewhere
yeah I mean that may be exactly the same
huh
yeah just about
just about let's see
a little bit different this is flat
across here and then the bridge comes
out on this one
they're the same size yeah
Ben says so all this time with those
funky big glasses you haven't actually
been able to see us no the um the ones
that are more cat eye yeah these ones
that I wear usually these are readers so
I can see in these
yeah like the big round ones I didn't
usually ever wear them on the show
because I couldn't see in them and
that's why
so all of your comments would have just
been a blur
but I've wore them in photos and stuff
like that but I can't actually see in
them so that's why
uh Warby Parker is cheap as far as
glasses go I'll have to look on there I
didn't think it would be that hard to
like find reading glasses that were
shaped like this they were just like big
and round but it was like really a [__]
I don't know why you really can't get
them in the United States you got to go
to a foreign vendor I mean they have
like millions of other different kinds I
don't know why this was so it's not that
weird
and once you do find a costume
yeah like I had yeah like I found
costume ones with but I can't see in
those
um Oracle says Hey Wednesday's show has
had an unexpected sequel here my husband
grew up in Friendswood Texas yeah uh
where um that's where the Andrea eats
thing happened yeah
and his parents both worked for NASA so
I asked him if his dad was there when
Rusty Yates was at JSC he said he wasn't
sure but he and Rusty were in the Boy
Scouts together hmm
wow
that's crazy
like does he remember him being like a
weirdo or anything
probably not I don't remember hardly
anything from my childhood so I wouldn't
really know I mean it's not I don't
remember anything it was just
nothing all that
exciting happened I guess so and I don't
remember a lot of kids I do I do
remember going to school with a kid
in first grade
who many years later murdered somebody
he wasn't a serial killer or anything
but he murdered somebody I can't
remember what the circumstances were
and I only remembered him because he was
a ginger and he had like a weird name
but I didn't remember anything else
about him you know what I mean I thought
he was kind of weird but that was about
it
Oracle said he remembers him being into
good music like King Crimson okay
Yeah Boy Scouts what age would that have
been were they like pre-teens or
teenagers or whatever
he tells you something about my
husband's tasted music
I don't mind King Crimson actually
but uh but yeah
that's what uh that's really really
crazy
I know we kind of like dunked on Rusty a
lot like on that show but
I don't I don't really feel bad
I don't really feel bad
I'm sure like he's an okay dude and
maybe he has a good life now and stuff
like that but
he just uh
contributed to to that whole situation
uh yeah Oracle said well my husband made
Eagle Scout yeah I was in the Girl
Scouts when I was little
I didn't go that far in it though I was
just I just just at the sold cookies and
learn how to do knots stage
so he was a scout until he was about 17
or so dang
yeah some people I had a cousin that
stayed in like all that time
um granther says streamate is a trip
yeah he's been on stream mate I guess uh
ugly [__] wrinkled old porn stars
Colombians constantly drinking he has a
lot of Columbians in there and uh nap
cams with tip Vibe on so randos can give
money as someone sleeps it's all weirdly
fascinating yeah hey maybe maybe I
should get into that I could just lay
there and precise
yeah every now and then like snore
you fail to mention all the hotties that
are on there though you must not be
looking at the right times you got
Fitness chicks in there you have to
filter out you can filter out a lot of
stuff filter out Colombia all the
Central and South America because
there's a lot of them on there so it'll
be like it'll be like five or six pages
yeah of Colombians like before you even
get anything yeah
you gotta you you only want the
English-speaking world that's the first
selection in the um
in the filter function
I don't even look at Europe or Eastern
Europe because you're just gonna
you're not gonna be able to interact
with them
yeah so you know
yeah we usually just speak with it stay
with the English speakers yeah just
English speaking but if you go to
English speaking and all of a sudden it
whittles it all down to where at any one
time there's only like two or three
couples on it in the English-speaking
world at any one time
yeah we get that couples action
yeah last time we streamed man it was a
couple that was in there that was a
customer he had me call her name out and
[__]
yeah it was good yeah Tuesday we
streamed Tuesday night we didn't stream
last night because I was too tired but
Tom was too tired yeah we didn't get a
lot of sleep well we streamed for about
an hour we profited probably about what
30 30 bucks probably something like that
yeah we were oh yeah we were only on for
like an hour maybe yeah
yeah
he uh
we're average in about 20 25 an hour
it's not bad it's only like two
customers That's like [__] 10 minutes
maybe 15 minutes yeah you don't really
have to do much because like I said if
somebody goes private or exclusive
that's like 4.99 5.99 a minute yeah so
you know they're in there for five
minutes I mean that's a pretty good
chunk of change and you don't really
have to do all that much they're just
trying to there's like hey do this or do
that or whatever
for like a few minutes and then yeah
they're already [__] primed and ready
to go by the time they press the [__]
the [__] private button they're not
gonna last long well yeah because they
don't say something sideways in the
[__] oh man it was great okay
okay I'm done
well yeah I mean like I said it's kind
of expensive and if you aren't already
ready
[__] in hand yeah then it's then it'll
add up it's gonna add up so a lot of
times you know they're already ready
those dudes are [__] pre-gaming on
you yeah I'm sure yeah and then um
sometimes you're doing a show for one
and like two or three to one or two
other ones will jump in and watch yeah
because if you go private like other
people private just means like one
person will pay for private but then
other people can like buy it right yeah
too but exclusive is just it's more
expensive and you just go yeah no one
can buy no one else can buy anything
they can turn their camera on yeah we've
only had that happen one time like the
first or second time we streamed yeah
one person did I think it was your first
customer I think so first or second but
yeah like nobody else has really
um asked about or even seemed like they
wanted to do it and it was just some 22
year old kid yeah he was normal yeah
normal guy well like I said it was like
everybody watches PornHub
yeah it's um
it's a trip
yeah said for every hot either 10 not so
much yeah yeah but the thing is is that
they're getting action
yeah ever like everybody gets action
pretty much because there's so many
people on there yes people forget that
there's a certain kind of customer that
that really only wants to interact at
that level with somebody kind of like at
their level so their customers look like
them they're they're about like that
yeah I mean you would think that you
know it was just like the hottest chicks
or whatever that got the top but not
always
not always
um because we're I'm always kind of
interested like at different time
periods like who were the top because
who's at the top because yeah they have
it in order like whoever's getting the
most action at that particular time
they're always like at the top of the
list and she gets to the top so it's
like but it's not always like the ones
you would think that it was you know
what I mean which I always found really
interesting
so the ones in the top ten
in a busy
at a busy time
It's usually the girls that are hustling
the most yeah interacting a lot or
talking a lot and they're just sucking
slamming out little [__] private
shows [__] three minutes here five
minutes there three minutes there and
they're making ninety dollars an hour
because you know
they're almost booked solid
Yeah because sometimes you click on the
people and it's like oh they're lazy
yeah and then they're back and then
they're in a private show and then
they're back and they're just back and
forth and back and forth and then dudes
are buying in and sometimes
they're busy so one guy bought the show
but then three or four other guys paid
in and she's getting 5.99 per person
right so that [__] [__] ahead like I
said wait adds up yeah
and I was it's crazy because
um I just got the first check from there
from our first week where we only
streamed a three hours four hours and it
was already like 72 dollars so and it's
like so we're sitting there going well
[__] I mean if we had time to like
stream for
six hours a day like not all at once but
you know two two and two yeah you could
do like two hours a year take a break
two hours there take a break or
something like that it's like you could
like make some decent money see Bill
my friend Bill his wife more than happy
more than half of their income comes
from stream maple
she um
she streams her name is Amy Quinn she's
a mid-level porn star
she uh she streams about 30-ish hours a
week
she makes over six figures it's yeah six
figures and some
only on 30 hours a week and right now
it's it's at this it's at this it's
summer so it's slow
uh it's it's a basically kind of like a
life support because there's not a lot
of traffic
and he says he's never seen it Go below
twenty dollars an hour and that checks
out with us yeah I mean even even when
it's because Tuesday night it was kind
of dead we didn't really have that many
people come in but we still made twenty
dollars and we were only on for like
maybe a little less than an hour yeah
and you're not working for an hour no
you're mostly just kind of sitting there
and like people are coming in yeah
running in the background trying to keep
you in the mood drinking we're [__]
with each other you can't really see
what's going on but below the belt and
then all of a sudden [__] customer
starts talking to you and then weak and
then I'll try to talk about she's she
doesn't she she's doesn't really hustle
she's not a salesperson
but I'll talk him at a tournament I mean
that's that's your strength not mine
yeah you got to learn it I know but it's
I'm just not good at that and um she's a
little bashful so I just at times I kind
of play off for her being bashful in the
in the private
you know once they go private
only that customer can see what the
hell's going on in there there are only
people that pay against them that's what
I said yes only that customer okay I can
do that now if it's private other people
can buy in but it's rare
if it's exclusive nobody else can buy in
and he could turn his camera on yeah but
they tend not to yeah I've only had that
happen one time and I think they pay
extra
yeah I'm not sure how that works I can't
really like I don't know there's nowhere
where you can charge extra I thought it
was just a perk that came with maybe I
don't know uh private or exclusive
because I remember to ask us a question
when it came to setting prices when we
were setting up the we were setting up
the channel
and it asked us what how much we wanted
for them to be able to turn on the
camera
I don't remember that question yeah I
remember it because you were like I
don't know if I want to return on the
camera you left it zero so I think it's
free to turn on the camera
well I'd have to go back in there and go
back and chat well because I went in
there to like to change the prices but
now I don't know where that yeah
original setup thing was yeah it was
during when we first set up the the the
profile itself
but now I can't find it right so I don't
know and of course uh you know videos on
sale there I imagine you probably got
you picked up some videos while you're
in there the right Grabbers
the problem is the problem is is that um
because of the streamate rules we can't
post any of the material that has me in
it not even my voice even though I can
stream where they're live and I think we
can even record the live streams yeah we
can well if we record the live streams
can it be sold not on there not on you
can sell it elsewhere it's ridiculous
well this weekend we're gonna set up
many vids yeah that'll have me on it
um and see how and hopefully that's not
a huge pain in the ass but we're gonna
set that up because you know and then we
can sell because as far as I know
streamate does allow you to sell the
same videos on that site as you sell on
other ones like it doesn't have like
exclusive rights on it or anything yeah
so I can sell the same ones that I'm
selling on streamate which are just me
right um but then I can sell the ones
that are both of us too and some of
those some of the ones that are for sale
on streamate will have better edits
more hardcore edits on minivids and I'll
be in it yeah
but there are some of them that she
edited down too much that have to be
opened back up one of them that I'm
thinking of in her best one really
she cut the best parts of it out I was
like why'd you do that because those are
mistakes and I was like no that's what
the dudes are looking for
well you know yeah but that's just a
mistake I have a true mistake
she doesn't understand
what guys like really
thanks Tom
you know you don't you don't watch porn
well I do because you make me watch it
all the time well you have to so well
that's what I mean it's like I don't
really mind watching it and to be honest
with you but sometimes it's different
when it's you though because like
sometimes when it's me I'm just kind of
like man I really like that angle and I
don't really like this and that and the
other thing yeah because I'm always like
critical it's not so much that oh I
don't think dudes like that it's just
that I personally don't like how it
looks you know what I mean yeah so I
would take it out because the thing
about it well the thing about it is that
you know I would actually prefer to just
shoot another one yeah that I liked
better we could do what I mean well
that's what I mean because I was
thinking well I could just shoot another
one that I liked what I was saying is
some of the stuff you edited out
looked fine from a guy's point of view
just a year too critical well yeah
because like I said because it's me so
I'm gonna be like obviously I'm always
more critical of myself than anyone else
I wasn't seeing what you were seeing
right so it's just like that's what I
mean but that's that's true of everybody
everybody is always more critical of
themselves than other people are well at
least like yeah I don't know like
creative people are for sure
um yeah you said I'm not creative no I'm
just saying that I'm just saying most
people are critical of themselves uh
grandpa says amazing how many performers
are on there 10 hours a day seven days a
week yeah I mean they you make a lot of
money if you're on there that much they
got bills to pay
right and the thing about it is that I
mean eventually we would like to get to
a point where we can do like I said you
know six to eight hours like a regular
work day kinda but like break it up yeah
you don't want to do it solid yeah and
you and I don't want to do it like every
single day you know what I mean because
I want to have days off and [__] like
that because otherwise I'd go [__]
crazy yeah but um I would do I would do
three two hour sessions or
yeah or something like or four two-hour
sessions something like that or maybe
three three hour sessions that might
work too
you do a morning a
middle of the day and a late night
version and a late night one
you know it ends at 11. right 9 10 11.
Ben says have you quit your job man
no not yet not yet
but no not yet had to make sure all the
money was good and everything has to be
right yeah when paycheck's coming in and
Bill's being ready probably next
probably another bug now I did take
because I had some paid
days off so I did take
um some days off next week like I'm
working Monday Tuesday Wednesday but
then I took Thursday Friday and the
following Monday off
so hopefully we'll be able to stream
more and like maybe make some more
videos and [__] like that like on those
days because I'll be home all day so
I'll be home like five days in a row
which will be nice
so
we'll see how that goes granther said
what is the red Gizmo hanging for most
performers bottoms it looks like a
Sci-Fi tampon oh that's that damn
Wireless second vibrator that's what
she's taught that's what he said yeah
there's because streammate and a lot of
the other uh streaming sites have a
thing where you can have interactive sex
toys yeah and you set it up through the
platform and people can tip you and they
have an app on their phone that controls
your vibrator yeah like from there
that's so that's what that is a lot of
people have those they make money off of
them but it's useless for us because
we're a couple
yeah I don't really think that it would
just be investing in one of those
because they're not cheap no those
things that's something for a solo
female performer
yeah I feel like that's more like along
those lines but that's what that is what
is it called it's called love sense or
something like that I love it but it's a
particular kind of sex toy that's
interactive and you can
so people that are real hardcore into
the [__]
download an app on their face got one
and then they tip you and then like
Amy's got one she says her Bill said
that she said it's useless it just makes
money well yeah that's what I mean they
pay to turn it on right so you know they
did the numbers and you know they make
several thousand dollars a year off that
and it's like you turn it off well yeah
the dude's just gonna turn it on and
it's like not right you're not gonna be
like oh well it's not really doing
anything I particularly like but okay
like an egg and it's got a wire that
comes around and it hits on her [__]
button there and [__] we didn't fire
the whole thing vibrates uh yeah it hits
it on a [__] but it [__] it doesn't
evidently it's just not a big deal
uh according to Amy it's just mostly
annoying but she's like yeah yeah money
money thank you you know like I said
yeah I could see that how that would be
really annoying because it's like just
some random dude yeah yeah yeah smashing
the buttons on there yeah I'm gonna like
make her [__] scream man and you're
just like yeah yeah
[Laughter]
this is uh entertainment man it's a show
it's Show Business
yeah they're selling fantasy sure that's
only that's all yeah it is it's it's
difficult but there's a lot of tricks
involved in it and uh our show isn't
totally 100 tight yet that's what part
of the reason why we don't stream for
very long because we'll go in and we'll
try something which is yeah that works
pretty well and then we'll do it helps
you kind of like get the ACT down
um
and there's a bunch of different ways
you can do there's a bunch of different
ways you can do this a bunch of
different angles so you can do it from
and you got to find out which one works
best for you
so instead of wasting a whole day
[__] doing something
we'll go on there for a couple hours and
try a new angle and see how well that
did they're all about the same seems
like no matter what you do you're going
to make twenty dollars an hour on if
it's if if it's slow
but it's still worth it because
really out of that 20 out of that hour
you might have gotten
ten dollars worth of tips
just of [__] that you did in public
we've did that we've had them just come
in and says tell me to give you money
okay give me some money and they gave us
some money and then yeah like a like a
sub like a sub they just wanted us to
yell at them so we yelled at them that
we wanted some money and then I'm like
wow
I'll talk rough to him you know what I
mean call him a pig and shitty little
piggy you know oh yeah that's right yeah
yeah I remember that person yeah so
ah
[Laughter]
so you're going to make about 20 25 an
hour [__] on life support
but it's supposed to be more towards the
winter
when people aren't out for the summer
people are more indoors evidently the
traffic picks up well yeah because that
what what what's the matter no you can't
go in there she dancing going to class
oh for heaven's sakes she saw in there
earlier there's nothing yeah no
random though
I want to go in a class but when it's
good
if you're on a real roll
it's like 90 bucks an hour
and you you and maybe it's only because
instead of two five minute shows an hour
you're getting like six
then other dudes are jumping and
watching yeah which like I said that's
it's fairly easy money it's a
casino-like environment yeah you can um
try you can do a different angle like
you said we're gonna have a gold show
and that's a show and you're gonna say
the show will be and you can stipulate
and and you you're kind of like
you're telling the platform okay we're
gonna start a gold show we want the show
to start
the countdown will be 20 minutes
it'll be
uh
300 gold
and one gold is equal one dollar so 300
gold
and it's going to be a 15 minute show
uh or 20 minute show or a half hour show
and during the show we're gonna do this
this and this and this all right
countdown will start 40 minutes from now
so it starts counting down and guys will
[__] see
the show is going to start in 40 minutes
the show will start when they hit 300
gold
everybody who pays in gets to see it
it's going to be a half hour long
as I start 40 minutes so some guys will
go and if you don't start the show he
gets his money back it's in his wallet
he's got a wallet inside
um stream mate
so some guys will come in and go uh yeah
okay that's 15 minutes from now all
right here's 30 gold I'll watch that
and then they're waiting to see if the
if you reach the 300 limit the 300 goal
if you don't reach the 300 goal it might
be
only 100 gold
you said we're going to do the show
anyway
and then the guys there might be three
guys that paid
came up with a hundred bucks they get to
see the show
now the 100 gold you don't get all that
because you only get 30 uh
was it 35 yeah yeah streamate takes the
rest yeah
so you're gonna make 35 off that
so it probably wouldn't have been a good
price really to do it for a hundred but
it's better than to let it walk away
yeah I mean that's so you make dollars
is better than zero dollars yeah you can
make 35 in a half hour
that's 60 something dollars an hour yeah
which is not bad at all seventy dollars
an hour it's a lot more than I make at
my job right
so you know and then you know you might
do a couple of those a day
it would add up we still haven't done we
haven't [__] around with the gold show
yeah like we've mostly just been making
money just yeah kind of sitting in the
room and like people
um you know just asking us like hey go
private and they want to see this that
and the other thing and it's just like a
few like five minutes or something it
would make sense of something like
a 500 gold show
you know what I mean and you want to get
like [__]
10 guys each one paying 50 bucks and
it's going to be about an hour long show
right and during that show they there's
stuff that they can do
they can communicate with you in certain
ways I think they I think some of them
can turn cameras on and stuff
I don't have to go back and check check
what the rules are or some of them can
send audio
there's different rules for that I gotta
I gotta study more more up on gold show
but they got some people some girls that
just run that now usually the girls that
run gold shows
tend to be famous porn stars
and sometimes they'll get a thousand
gold but she's famous
Show's gonna start at an hour it's going
to be a two hour long show
you know she's gonna talk and [__]
around and play with toys and interact
with the with the crowd it's not
straight sex it's not
she might [__] dance and do a strip
tease or playing with toys or
her husband or boyfriend who's rated
who's passed through the
ID checks can jump in and get her or
another performer
sometimes just two porn stars
if they're already approved to be on
stream mate it's they can use the facial
recognition and be on the same show
together if they know where they live
they can meet up and do it
John Robertson said hey Jenny and Tom
nice to change the subject I had a
question for you Jenny I wanted to ask
your opinion how
with a Vampire can I have them have an
aversion to crosses without it being
religious I'm trying to come up with a
Vampire novel in time I wanted your
opinion too I think I've read and I
can't forgive me if I can't remember
exactly what the details were yeah I
have seen some angles where they're like
well the cross only works if the person
wielding it has faith in it and that's
so much that and it could be anything
but yeah so it could be anything it
doesn't necessarily have to be a cross
it could be anything that somebody has
faith in it's mental domination or I
have seen it done too where
um sometimes it's something else about
the cross that
repels the vampire like what it's made
of or I don't know just like the idea
surrounding it or something like that so
you can maybe go that route be more
realistic if it was if it was faith
because it's just mental domination and
will
well in um you can get the vampire to go
away because you want him to go away
that's that's in having faith in in in
something
can is all you have a real strong faith
in something even if it's yourself or
your own abilities you'd be able to
repel the [__]
well that was kind of a component of um
fright night you know from the 80s 1985.
um because he could actually just like
Crush across his hand the vampire could
if the person wielding it Adam didn't
have faith in it but if you did actually
have faith in it then it would work but
otherwise it wouldn't well think about
it man
at vampire in the stories could look at
you and mentally dominate you and tell
you to do something you would do it so
it stands the reason it that's probably
a weakness it may have too you can flip
it back you could tell it to do
something
yeah if your will is strong enough
yeah that might be a good idea and the
the cross would just be kind of like
a placebo
yeah so that's what I mean so it doesn't
necessarily have to be across I think
that like some stories have come at it
from that angle if I'm remembering
correctly I don't read a great deal of
vampire stuff anymore because it's not
really my favorite thing maybe dude
remember when Bella looked at [__]
van Helsey goes come here come here
and then he resisted he goes oh you're
strong well
what if you were [__] head of strong
enough mind where you could look at
Dracula and go come here and he and he
can't resist it you know he's okay
it might go both ways like a psychic
link
yeah that might be yeah but you had to
be really psychically strong you know
yeah
then Oracle said silver content of the
Cross yeah that's what I was thinking I
think I've seen stories that it was done
like that where it had to be like what
the cross was made of like it's made of
silver iron or something like that I'd
go with the psychic angle
yeah that would seem like a good because
like I said it's been
sort of done before but vampires have
psychic abilities like mental domination
but they're also susceptible to it
that's that's how like somebody else has
there's somebody else's real mentally
dominant that they can fall prey to it
that's the way I would play it
Camp guy said just watch the movie knock
at the cabin the M night uh Shyamalan
one I had been wanting to see that not
because it was M Night Shyamalan because
his movies lately been kind of sucky but
um but because I really really liked the
novel that it's based on which was not
called knock at the cabin it was
actually called the cabin at the End of
the World by Paul Tremblay and it was a
really really good book now so I wanted
to see the movie but then I kind of
heard mixed reviews of it and I was like
well now I don't know if I want to watch
it because the book was so good and I
don't really know I don't know maybe I
should watch the movie so I can do like
a uh comparison because I like to do
like the novel to
movie comparison like on my other
channel so maybe I'll watch it and see
how it turned out although I'll probably
have to reread the book again because I
don't remember exactly what happened and
it was a while back that I read it
but um yeah where let's see yeah the
cross can help you focus your will
that's part of it yeah that's true
ritual any kind of ritual would help you
focus your will so by these same rules
of course you know a Jedi would be able
to [__] up a vampire If he if the Jedi
understood what a vampire was has
anybody made a Jedi versus vampires
movie I'm sure somebody has right well
there's got to be vampires in the Star
Wars movie because the Sith is a witch
really it's a warlock yeah basically
they're doing a lot of the same things
that warlocks and witches would want to
do
you know live forever bring back the
dead that kind of thing and you could
kind of say that maybe Darth Vader was a
vampire in a certain way
um because I'm pretty convinced based on
what Darth Sidious has said about Darth
plague as the wise and how Vader got
nearly birded up and killed and he sees
him down he goes that's good it's not
too late
and then later on Vader's sand tells
Luke no I you don't understand the power
of the dark side I can't betray
my master
it had to have been that
he was keeping Vader from dying
and he was somehow
Vader was supposed to be dying but the
suit was helping to keep him alive or or
kept him active but I believe Darth
Sidious
his master was feeding him Life Force to
keep him from dying
now so he was kind of feeding off of
Darth Sidious in a way like way of
vampire will but like a psychic vampire
that's what I was going to say it was
wrong no you might say well wouldn't
that weaken
Darth Sidious if he's got to give up
some of his
Force essence or his soul to keep
Vader alive and I say well I think what
happened was is that he sucked the soul
out of Padme that's why she died
and he was feeding
Vader padme's Soul somehow
yeah that actually makes a lot of sense
he gained it he gained an additional
life from Padme and kept it somehow in
spiritual storage and then was feeding
it through him into Vader he had an
extra life
and he was slowly feeding it out so
Vader couldn't betray him he'd cut him
off from the from the from from being
fed this life force and he would have
died that's why when he killed Sidious
and
[__] Luke says let me take this mask
off because he goes take this mask off
and look says yeah you'll died he says
nothing can stop that now
and it's because Sidious was gone
right cities was keeping him alive and
he slowly just faded away died away
so that's the only explanation it's the
only thing it could have been
yeah like I said that makes total sense
actually yeah so and that's like
something a witch would do
in a witch story yeah I'll give you life
and keep you from dying but I gotta have
a I gotta have a life to Rob
you know a soul to steal and I'll feed
you that Soul over time so I think
that's what happened to Padme
because the robots couldn't explain why
she was dying there's she's slipping
away she's dying we we don't know why
so he took all her [__] energy man
yeah
Sidious was sucking it out of her
[__] for a long distances you know he
could invade your dreams and have you
have nightmares of his choice and stuff
he knew what was going on remotely he
had
remote knowledge well he could kill
somebody by thinking about it steal
their soul remotely also if you were
susceptible man that would be a really
dangerous power for me to have that's
for sure that's why there were only two
there couldn't be a whole bunch of Sith
they'd kill each other
so there's only two like I'm thinking
you dead no I'm thinking you dead yeah
it'd be that it'd be that whole
situation
well they'd all be vying for power well
yeah and in the Sith system there was
only two a master and Apprentice
and the Master's job was to make an
apprentice that make an apprentice and
to give him only the powers he needed to
complete his missions and then the the
the the
apprentice's job was to learn as much as
he could from the master and eventually
kill him and take his place
and that was like on purpose that was
the stated purpose of those two
so they weren't friends really in the
way he would think the word friend
the Sith student was a slave actually
and his job was to get stronger and to
get free and to kill his master
and then do do the same thing to
somebody else make an apprentice there
couldn't be any more than two
or the or they they [__] cause all
kinds of damage they'd all kill each
other
because they were going to kill each
other anyway that's what that's what
their job was is that the struggle for
dominance
but it only took two of them to destroy
the entire [__] Jedi Order and
[__] take over the dab known Galaxy
that
which is uh
goes back to uh what I've told you many
times on this show is that evil is
stronger than good and it says that
right there in return to the Jedi
when um Luke is being trained by Yoda
he's running with your little Yoda on
his back and he goes and he goes uh you
know fear and anger you know don't give
into the dark side yeah the light side's
good isn't it he goes no
clear your mind don't ask any questions
so that's a trick answer from Yoda
you know the light side is stronger than
the dark and he says no clear your mind
don't ask questions
no the dark side was Stronger it was
because it was about destruction it's
harder to create things than it is to
destroy things even though creation and
destruction are the same act it's just
if you create a house you got to destroy
trees that kind of thing
so but uh
no
just two Sith [__] up all those damn
Jedi just through treachery treachery is
a lot more effective lies are far more
effective than the truth
and it stated over and over again it's
all Buddhist philosophy and
Friedrich Nietzsche
you know our artist copenhower they talk
about all this that
truly talented evils [__] much
stronger than good
Oracle says hey is anybody else here
seeing the Renfield movie Ben said I
have silly fun uh and Oracle said I
enjoyed it more than I thought I would
and Tammy said she really
liked it I still have not watched it I
and I really need to because it looks
amazing
and uh let me see
oh and Ben said I like the vampires in
the necroscope books where they're
ancient alien things that live
underground and infect people to try and
eat them later on necroscope that was um
Brian Lumley right I haven't I don't
think I've read those actually if I did
then it was a very long time ago like I
said I don't
I used to be real into vampire stuff
like when I was a teenager
and in my 20s and stuff like especially
like after I read Anne Rice like back in
the 80s and then I got real into vampire
stuff but I don't know I just haven't
read a lot of vampire stuff and it's and
it's um kind of sometimes I'll like pick
out a book if you watch my book reviews
you've seen this happen probably a
couple times but it's like sometimes
I'll pick out a book at random without
realizing it's a vampire book and then
I'm reading it I'm like oh it's vampires
like I'm always kind of like a bummed
out about it because vampires are not
really my favorite monster
I'm more into I like haunted house
stories I really like haunted house
stories ghost stories I really like old
school witch kind of [__]
um and like weird surrealist
psychological horror
so anything that's like Monsters is like
a harder sell for me depending on what
kind of monster it is but if it's
usually if it's one of the like regular
monsters like vampires or werewolves or
something like that I'm like not as into
that just because it's everything's been
done I feel like
you know so I'm always kind of like
looking for something that hasn't been
done but I have read a lot of good
vampire [__] though
like I read one a couple years ago that
I actually didn't know was a vampire
book going into it and then I was like
oh vampires but I was like oh but it's
still good though
um and it was called dark corner by
Brandon Matthew I think was the name of
the author
and that was actually pretty good and
that was straight up vampires
uh Oracle said oh I have haunted house
recommendations for you Jenny a house
with good bones by T Kingfisher oh yeah
I've been wanting to read that because
I've read some of um T kingfisher's
other stuff that and I really really
liked it
so
that will probably be next on my list I
think the one I'm putting up tomorrow if
I get a chance to record it is another
Grady Hendricks book because I finished
reading that this week
um
called we sold our souls and then I had
I bought
um
slew foot by Brahm and so that'll
probably be the next book review I
haven't started it yet because I just
finished the other one but so that might
be the next book probably like in a week
or two
but I have some non-fiction stuff too
that I gotta read but I haven't got
around to it yet because I just don't
have a lot of time but you know what I
mean uh yeah Oracle said it's good yeah
I've I've really liked um T kingfisher's
other stuff that I've read because I've
read like a couple of theirs but yeah
and if it's a haunted house thing and
it's like funny because haunted house
stuff either there's like a million
Haunted House books and Haunted House
movies and stuff like that but man
that's I don't know why it's just like
my favorite probably my favorite
sub-genre of horror I think is just like
creepy
paranormal haunted house stuff
because it's
I don't know it's hard to mess that up
it's hard to mess that up because
everybody can relate like most people
live in a house except for homeless
people sadly but most people live in a
house and it's like you can relate to
it's like oh this is my house where I
you know I think it's my safe space and
everything like that and then all of a
sudden like all this [__] crazy
paranormal [__] starts happening you're
like oh [__] I don't have anywhere to
escape to so it's like that's inherently
scary and it's inherently scary to most
people because they can relate to it you
know what I'm saying
um
Oracle says if you haven't heard by the
way T Kingfisher has been diagnosed with
breast cancer oh [__] but she's handling
the treatment okay man that sucks I had
the feeling that she wasn't that old but
I don't really know like a lot about her
to be honest
because I've only read a couple of her
things but
but yeah
Ben says the main character the
necroscope can channel the spirits of
the Dead to get advice and even get them
to take over his body to do fights or
stunts for him oh that would be handy
um I've just been
listening to
uh if you I know some of you guys like
to listen to like scary stories and
stuff like that like on YouTube because
I like to listen to them while I'm
driving and stuff because they're
relaxing
and um I really like this guy named
Busta who is
I guess he's Australian like his accent
sounds Australian and I like his stuff
because he'll put up like three four
hour videos and they're usually
um compilations like just of a bunch of
stories that he got from you know no
sleep subreddit or whatever or that
people have sent him but I listened to
one over the past couple days that was
actually one big long story and it was
like three or four hours long so it was
almost like a like a novella length and
I think I don't know what the title
title of it was and I don't know who
wrote it but the you know the um
the what you call it the thumbnail said
something like I think my grandfather is
a serial killer and so I started
listening to that one and I listened
that holy [__] that was a great [__]
story what a great [__] story that
was it was like really really well
written and it's just
I don't know man it was just like really
good and I'm like I can't believe that
I'm imagining that somebody wrote this
big long thing because like I said it's
three or four hours like it took him to
read it and they wrote this big long
thing and I'm presuming that they just
like put it up for free somewhere I'm
like they need to make a movie out of
this [__] this is great you know what I
mean like I got really into it so I'm
gonna have to listen to like some of his
more
long ones because usually I'm just kind
of like well I'm driving and it's like I
kind of like the shorter ones because
then I don't have to like go back to it
and I'm like oh yeah what happened again
like because I you know can't listen to
it all at once but I'm kind of I'm
really glad that I listened to that one
because it was really [__] good
but it took me like three days to like
listen to it just going back and forth
uh Oracle said she's about your age
oh 46 so she's younger than me oh [__]
that's scary
breast cancer at 46. but I mean I don't
have I've been checking there's no lumps
thanks Tom
thanks Steven Seagal yeah
check it checking the breast cancer
[Laughter]
yeah yeah that's what he's doing yeah
but I mean we I mean we do have uh
friends that are my age
we have a friend that's my age maybe a
year or two older that had that got
breast cancer yeah she was Minnie Mouse
one of the many she's doing okay though
I haven't seen her in a while she hasn't
been out but yeah
we see her um her boyfriend all the time
because he works at Barbarella yeah she
used to work uh she used to work at
Disney yeah she's one of the Minnie
Mouse's little bitty or Mickey Mouse I
think she's the Mickey Mouse
yeah she's a little tiny woman yeah
but uh but yeah she had to go through
all the
all that [__]
you know
sucks man
I just I I'm just kind of like I know
I'm good to that age but I'm just kind
of like man I just I don't even want to
know
I don't want to know
you know what I mean you know you don't
you don't have any signs of any kind of
illness you're in good shape you got
good genes man nothing even happened to
your mom
yeah
she had a minor heart attack yeah a
couple years back Southern diet
yeah well there there's that yeah and
and she doesn't work out like you do
yeah I mean that's the thing yeah but
other than that I mean we've kind of
always been
me and my siblings we've always been
somewhat healthy
actually when I was growing up
even when I was a kid I hardly ever got
sick
like every like even other people in my
family would get like oh my God I got
the flu or I got chickenpox or something
like that I've never seen her get sick I
would get it for like a day and then
it'd be like man then it would go away
and I'd be like and they'd be like man
you suck
I've I haven't gotten the flu
I don't even remember the last time I
got the flu
um
I don't even remember the last time I
had a cold
two years ago yeah
something
I mean you're talking about
genes and longevity
genetics are a factor
because if if you have
bad genes in terms of like a lot of
history of cancer and diabetes and stuff
in your family you really got to watch
it means you're very susceptible now
there's a lot of diabetes on my dad's
side of the family for sure yeah but was
it also was there also obesity
not so much on my dad's side no
because obesity is part of it men
uh
soap we're going over this a couple days
ago doing research
talking about aging and
what we're talking about is like why is
it women tend to fall off faster than
guys look at George Clooney look at
George Clooney when he was a kid and
look at him now
that [__] I wouldn't say he's
probably more attractive to a woman now
and what he was when he was
a kid on that program was that Facts of
Life or something what was the name of
that show he was on oh [__] now I can't
remember yeah he wasn't [__] yeah or
something like that yeah he was on one
of them 80s shows and then you look at
starlets that he came up with who were
like
real hot on Baywatch
not necessarily Pam Anderson but like
some of the women that worked with her
one of them that I was thinking of that
I was looking at
is younger than you she just turned 50.
she looks like [__] looks like [__]
it's hard to believe and it's weird
because like I'm not even famous and I
don't even have like access to plastic
surgeons or nutritionists or anything
like that you have me as a trainer a
little bit you have access to some
things
hormones stuff yeah but not very good
shape before that basically you know
you're in pretty good shape we both of
our weights would go up and down over
the years but still until because you're
a good cooking Tom yeah that was me
[__] eating my ass off feeding her
you made everything really really good I
mean tonight he made enchiladas and yeah
that [__] was delicious and I used
Claudia's recipe yeah this is the first
time he made them oh my God they were so
good yeah it's a good Channel it got
recommended to me uh I'm a Mexican
friend
um [__] Carnival he's he's sometimes
in the comment section I've showed his
[__] him and his handsome ass Sons
man his sons look like [__] Hollywood
movie stars
and he lives down in Tijuana and uh we
talk off we talk outside the show a lot
and it's been years now hadn't it known
him for probably [__] what eight nine
years yeah it's been a while we'll talk
about food and he'll send me pictures of
Mexican girls asses and [__] we're
judging the ass asology
Jenny knows what it is she's like what
the [__] you looking at it yeah like
glance over and it's like it's a big
picture of some chick's ass on there
yeah and I was like what do you think of
that one you know
it's it's allergies the study of the
phoenixology yeah so anyway um I'm gonna
make you a degree yeah that says that
that you can hang out boobology doctor
of assault so
he goes there's this girl who's uh
cooking and she's teaching in English
she does the shows in English her name
is cooking concludia
cone c-o-n means with in Spanish
and it's on YouTube I recommend it and
he he says all those all those recipes
are very modern Mexican recipes and that
they're that I can trust her palette and
the way she does [__] and she has a lot
of instant pot recipes
and she had instant pot
um enchiladas last week and I did a man
they're [__] good even though I
didn't use
beef I had a pork shoulder or pork butt
that's what I had I had a pork butt
and uh I just used that I just pressure
cooked it an hour and 20 minutes in salt
water with a half onion in it
man that pork came great it came out
good pulled pour it did you pull it and
then you take
the water
or the drippings from the pork butt
which is not a butt it's a shoulder of
believer up around the neck I always
wonder why they call it a pork but it's
not the point it's not a big butt yeah
it's not a butt so
take that water that's in that pot turn
it on simmer and you put peppers in
there had a bunch of fresh peppers I had
uh like uh some Serranos and I had some
jalapeños and I had some just some other
red peppers that I had and some dried
red Mexican chilies and put those in the
water and simmer it with an onion
and some garlic in there no no no not
the garlic and I had had an onion in
there
and then
scooped all that stuff about 20 30
minutes to scoop all those Peppers out
put them in a big I had them in a one
gallon pitcher put them in there and I
put about six cups of the broth that
came out of the cooking pot in there
and blended it with an immersion blender
and that's what I made my enchilada
sauce out of that's the way Claudia made
it man man [__] was
now it wasn't quite red enough for me so
I squirted a bunch of damn ketchup in
there you're like well ketchup what the
[__] yeah I mean trust me trust me it's
tomato paste yeah that's all it's got a
little bit of vinegar in it but sugar
but it Cooks out and it's got sugar but
sugar is great with salt and yeah and
sugar is great with salt and
um
hot chilies
it it
gets rid of a lot of the acidic flavor
and and tomato ketchup like from and I
use Heinz
um
it's got red dye in it so it'll make any
of your sauces get brighter red and nice
red color
and uh anyway that was the enchilada
sauce
take the corn tortillas and put them in
hot oil don't cook them all the way
leave them blonde and flexible pull them
out and just start stacking them up then
you put meat cheese in them roll them
put them in a band glass pan pour all
that enchilada sauce on top of cheese on
top of it 120 425 degrees about 15
minutes and it comes out just [__]
gorgeous
I mean it was really good damn served
with sour cream yeah really good beans
and rice on the side
or you know refried beans and uh yellow
rice we didn't I didn't serve that but
that's what it should have come with but
we had to keep the calories down well
yeah that it's honestly it was good like
that yeah you know because like I said
I'm trying not to overeat and the [__]
that's what I mean it's like you the
stuff you make is so good that it's like
I just want to eat and eat and eat and I
just can't I really have to like not do
that you know what I mean because I'll
weigh 400 [__] pounds yeah so I
forgot this is what I was getting at
Clooney this is like a very circular
circuitous route but we're coming back
to it
me and sofa watch we're looking at this
and and looking at we were talking about
it like yeah look at
how bad the women aged
but then you can pull up other examples
of women that age real well and you can
look at the difference you can see the
difference yeah I don't really think
it's a man-woman thing because there's
there's a behavior yeah there's a bunch
of male actors that you see that don't
look like ass too like when they get
older the the main difference the reason
why a lot of guys age better is because
the ones that age well or not live in
sedentary Lifestyles they're working out
they're actors that work out they take
hormone supplements they got a good diet
and they're staying away from drugs okay
if a woman just tries to keep a girlish
figure through diet not doing anything
that's not gonna work you must at least
later on in life after 30. you got to
start getting in the damn gym
or
because I can look at a person the way I
look at [__]
thoroughbred horses you can see the loss
of definition in certain areas and
what's happening the muscle atrophy
just the way fat distribution starts
piling on women in the areas
you can't just
Coast after 30 and expect to keep a good
figure with just diet alone
be it
any kind of diet it's got to have
exercise
the dudes that and then you go look at
the women who look fantastic there's
always diet and exercise involved
it's just that in general
women don't like to exercise they
definitely don't like to lift weights
and that's the most effective one
women that lift weights
not necessarily bodybuilders but just
women that lift weights last a lot
longer and they look better a lot longer
and I got examples of them in their 60s
and 70s
that lift
they never really got massive they
didn't become Mass monsters that wasn't
the idea they just were just doing
resistance training
and it just makes a world of difference
because you get definition and muscle
tone and it causes hormones to be
produced like HGH it can naturally be
produced through exercise
and it can help The Advocate system kind
of keep up there's limits to it
you know
um old people just don't make enough
hormones but if you supplement those
hormones
it starts paying back dividends
all them guys that look [__] great
after 40 and 50 they're all on [__]
HRT
testosterone replacement
they're just replacing what was lost or
[__] taking a lot more than what was
lost
it's just it's just obvious to me now
and that most of those guys are Fitness
guys or
actors
leading man type of Tom Cruise
definitely on [__] he's on test
he's got to be to be doing all this oh
yeah his age hell yeah he's on HRT
he's not sitting there trying to use
[__] Scientology [__] mental
powers to [__] keep his testosterone
production up they [__] he knows if
he was then nothing would be nothing
he's in jail because those powers are
not real yeah
OT Powers he's not using OT powers to
keep his testosterone levels High he's
injecting it
Ben said gotta go out now have a great
weekend and don't stream too hard yeah
thank you thank you you have a great
weekend too yeah well we'll probably
stream sometime this weekend
but we'll see how it goes oh that was
another thing that I wanted to bring up
oh Camp guys that I've seen her videos
uh cooking Claudia yeah uh she's good I
love my immersion blender he says yeah
immersion blender I mean I don't know
how it makes it makes great soup makes
good everything I can't believe I can't
believe that I lived without one of
those
yeah that's definitely like a good thing
to have in your kitchen it'll make
anything man you can make ice cream with
it yeah you make all kinds of [__] with
that
oh that was another thing we were gonna
discuss
was that we are thinking about
um not doing the haunting shows anymore
yeah and maybe moving the movie review
to Monday yeah we're gonna take a break
on The Haunting shows they're not
getting a real good response we don't
make anything on them
and they're starting to get kind of
samey
yeah and it's kind of a pain having to
watch them and like take notes on them
you can always revisit it but we might I
still want to do movie reviews though
because you guys seem to like those and
we like doing those and you know people
still send us movies and stuff like that
so I thought maybe we should move the
movie review to Monday night like where
the haunting is now like instead of
doing it on a Sunday we can do it
because then that way I don't know
should we do it this weekend I guess no
he doesn't care I don't care we'll
figure it out yeah we'll figure it out
but I don't know like I said we might we
might bring back a haunting at some
point but we've done a lot of the
episodes that were good yeah and we're
starting to scrape the bottom of the
barrel kind of and we're getting into
like the later ones where like we are
going to have to pay for them you know
yeah they're not that good they're not
as good
right and well they're just not getting
a really good response either
yeah people watch them but you know
whatever I mean I do kind of feel like
if and particularly with the with the
main shows on Wednesday I feel like True
Crime is always going to be more of a
draw yeah than paranormal stuff I know
some people do like the Paranormal stuff
we're not going to stop doing paranormal
stuff it's just that
whenever you start talking about serial
killers there's a big [__] spike in
our numbers
well you know and that's the thing I'm I
like talking about True Crime stuff more
than
paranormal stuff like the Paranormal
stuff is fun too but
I don't know I'm just way more in a true
crime and I think more people are like
into True Crime than they are normal
plus we gotta free up hours for our
other [__] Pursuits for our other
Pursuits yeah like I said it'll be to
make money it'll be easier when we go
um when we start doing it like more
full-time yeah which like I said we're
gonna try I'm trying to get Jenny back
in the house yes so we have more time
here to do it because it sucks because
now it's like you know not only do I
work full-time but I also have a commute
which is one hour each way so that's
another two hours that I waste every day
like in your car so that I could be
doing something else yeah like making
[__] 25 an hour [__] on down
right extremely and then like usually by
the time I get home I'm just so [__]
wiped out that's right because I don't
get much sleep because I have to get up
at five in the morning and I try to go
to bed early but that doesn't always
work out you know what I mean because I
have other [__] to do and I have other
and I have uh freelance [__] that I do
too like I usually have a lot of that
like over the week she's commuting two
hours a day
doing [__] that she could do from home
but they won't let her do it from home
it's added frustration
yeah you everything they're having to do
you can do it from here well you can
[__] telecommute
yeah that's the thing like a lot of well
like I said they during covid everybody
there worked from home yeah but then
they transitioned to working back in
there I don't know why well they're
gonna get a notice
Tammy says you're their best one they're
gonna get a notice I guarantee you
they're still gonna throw work your way
yeah maybe but like I said I have so
much stuff to eat freelance stuff anyway
that it's just kind of like
I get like a lot of that every week too
yeah so it's a well I was telling him I
was like sometimes I just feel like
um I get kind of like overwhelmed
because it just seems like
so much stuff just like piling on my
head you know what I mean yeah
yeah uh Tammy says so no Sunday show
yeah we might actually move the movie
review to Monday night I think I think
because then then that way we have all
weekend to like do our other [__]
I don't know
I would say yes either that or we could
still do the movie review on Sunday and
not do anything on Monday and then just
do streamate on Monday
's probably worse than Sunday
yeah Sunday we actually we streamed on
Sunday this week right this past Sunday
we did stream eight and it actually
wasn't bad
Tuesday was pretty dead but we still
made some money see the thing is is that
we're streaming at the worst times
according to bill the best time is on
this damn near morning right
it's not really not that good at night
those guys are out right yeah
people that have money go out and do
[__] well yeah must be nice yeah but um
just do have money yeah I know but
that's the thing it's like well if like
I said if we could get into it full time
then we could we won't have to do it
early early in the morning because I
still got to get up and put all the
makeup on and all that kind of [__] I
think you overdo it though
well I have toned it down some yeah
because man I used to the first times we
did it we did like a whole outfit and
like [__] fake uh lashes and all that
kind of crap they're not that they're
not that picky but yeah that's what I
mean after a while I was just kind of
like well they're really not that
Discerning so it's like I still do wigs
and like cool outfits yeah that's all
you need weird cool acts uh cool outfit
with a lot of easy access and this [__]
just gotta looks [__] that's it Jenny
tries to look nice and I'm like that
kind of works for them but they they're
they're gonna prefer [__]
you know which is a lot easier to do
just a little [__] party dress type
thing that's it
but you know like I said it's that's why
we kind of like bought a lot of stuff on
shoes because a lot of that stuff was
kind of
looked cool but was like you said easy
access yeah real stretchy
real minimalist
pretty much yeah they're gonna they're
just looking at the [__] hair in the
face
and really you don't really need the
lashes and
well it's like [__] contact lenses
aren't don't don't matter because they
can't really see that I mean I like
having those for photos just like photos
and like you know I like the lashes for
them but the thing about it is that when
we stream on streamate it's like I still
have to have the glasses on so I can see
everybody's comments and like what
they're asking us to do and stuff like
that so I have to wear the glasses and
it's like so when I wear fake lashes I
have a hard time wearing the glasses
because the glass is like oh hit the
lashes because the lashes are big so
it's always easier like not to wear them
and then the thing about I like the way
they look but then like uh the glue is
like stuck in my lashes for like two
days afterward and it's like so there's
like all this [__] glue like stuck in
there Tim is like they're not looking at
your lashes anyway no yeah
yeah well they're seeing everything
through the lens of account through the
lens of a
of a webcam
we're not if we don't have 4K
we got to get a new webcam though I want
that webcam yeah we haven't talked we
have we found one on Amazon that has
like a ring light attached yeah and I
think it's only like 60 or 69 or
something like that yeah that would make
things a lot easier if there was a light
on it yeah so we didn't have to yeah
grab it [__] go POV and [__] they're
asked for if they ask for [__] camera
angles and everything
dudes yeah I mean they're very specific
you know what they want yeah they want I
want doggy POV from the back but doesn't
happen okay yeah fine bro I know I know
exactly what he's talking about
tell her I want Joi okay all right
give him jly what's that I didn't
actually know what that was once you
said it I was like oh yeah I've heard
that before but I didn't yeah you know I
was in the middle of something else and
I was just kind of like it you know
shit's coming at me and I can't like
think of [__] that fast you know what I
mean like it didn't occur to me what
that was
[Laughter]
so I don't you know I don't know
and then it was kind of difficult too
because I had high-heeled shoes on yeah
which was a mistake and that was well I
told you it was a mistake and I don't
really like wearing those because they
can't see them anyway they can yeah
that's what I mean they can't see my
feet anyway and it's just kind of like
look if we're trying to like do some
complicated [__] like if somebody goes
private and stuff like that I'm just
gonna fall over on my goddamn face yeah
and that's not gonna look real sexy is
it yeah
The Velvet golf boots work though yeah
those
because you had those on camera a couple
times they liked them anything that's
kind of flat it's got to be flat yeah
because I'm you know
flat saw flat because I can't like I
said I can't be teetering around in
those [__] I'm gonna break my ankle
or my neck or something like trying to
do all this [__]
you know what I'm saying
it's that kind of crap
so uh what I could use some more ice
actually okay or actually maybe like
more I'm making a drink yeah
it's not quite empty but
yeah
oh
man I'm just I'm really looking forward
to having some days off next week I well
because I thought to myself look it's
like we're gonna try and do
the streaming thing full time eventually
like maybe in the next month or so
so I'm kind of like well the where like
the job I work at they do a thing where
you know you accrue and a lot of jobs
are like this I know well like were you
a crew PTO time like for however many
weeks you worked there like they give
you
what is it like one hour for every week
you work there or something like that so
I've been there long enough that I
accrued like 25 hours and I was like
well [__] that's like three days so I
mean I might as well take it because
I'll get paid for those three days and I
don't have to drive all that way and
I'll save gas money so
so that'll be nice it'll be like having
a five day weekend
looking forward to that
and then uh tomorrow
I'm actually not sure like what time but
tomorrow my sister is coming down from
Atlanta again and she has like um the
Disney annual pass she loves Disney so
she comes down every few months or
something and like does all the parks
and stays in one of the resorts and all
that kind of stuff
so she's
actually flew down today and she's
staying with my brother
my youngest brother Edwards I actually
have two brothers but staying with my
youngest brother over in Daytona so
she's gonna go to Magic Kingdom tomorrow
but she said like in the afternoon
evening she was going to go to Disney
Springs so I might go and uh hang out
with her there hopefully my brothers can
show up too because that's always really
fun we'll get all the four siblings
together but Disney Springs is good
because I told her I was like I can't as
much as I would love to go to like the
parks with her and stuff like that
because that'd be a blast
um I can't really afford it at the
moment because it's kind of expensive we
are planning on because she's gonna come
down again like right around my birthday
like at the end of September so we were
kind of planning on doing the Halloween
Disney thing because we did it last year
like she actually bought me a ticket to
go and we had such a good time it was so
fun
um so we're kind of planning on doing
that again and like what at least one of
my brothers is gonna is thinking about
coming along too and maybe his wife not
sure
so I'm kind of looking forward to that
so like well I'll save up money for that
but I can't really afford to go to the
parks now but Disney Springs is like
um it's just it's basically like a huge
open air it's not really like a mall
kind of but it's just like a big like
entertainment there's a big AMC Theaters
there it's like restaurants and bars and
just all kinds like shops and just all
kind of stuff and you can just like walk
around and look at everything and it's
like and it's pretty fun but like I said
it's you know you can just go there and
not spend a huge amount of money you
know you can just go and have some
cocktails and hang out like sit by the
water and [__] like that
so
that's maybe what we'll do tomorrow
we'll see what time because like I said
she said she'd go to the park and I
don't know how long she's gonna be there
I think she's going with my
sister-in-law and then they're going to
be there
in them she said she was going in the
morning and she had all this stuff
planned
so I don't know if it'll be evening
maybe Tom will go with me we'll see but
it should be fun I always like hanging
out with my siblings like I said I have
three siblings and they're all younger
like I have a brother that's four years
younger my sister is
seven years younger and my other brother
is
uh
uh 14 years younger yeah because he was
born in 86 86. yeah
but despite that large gap in our ages
like I said we're all very very similar
so when we all hang out together it's
always like a good time
I think the last time we did that we all
got together at
Disney we all ate at
what is that like Polynesian we all ate
the Polynesian
I think that was around Christmas time
because there was like all the
gingerbread houses and [__] like that
but that was really fun yeah we ate at
the Polynesian
for my no it was November because it was
my sister's birthday and her birthday is
the end of November but that was like
super fun because we had I don't it
sucks because I know I don't get to see
my siblings as much as I would probably
like do like my sister works at like
lives in um Atlanta
my other brother lives in Daytona which
you know I work there but I don't he
works too so I don't really he's an
electrician
and then my other brother lives out in
the middle of nowhere like in Ocala by
my mom
and we just never go over there because
I'm always scared to drive over to Ocala
because there's like no cell phone
service over there man it's like the
middle of nowhere
so it's like whenever I have to go visit
my mom and [__] like that I'm always
like scared and it's like my car is
going to break down on the way back and
it's gonna be night time and because
there's like nobody around there's no
lights there's no cell phone service
there's no nothing I'm like it's like a
[__] horror movie waiting to happen
they live out in a [__] Ocala
National Forest
yeah I'm laughing at Tammy saying nobody
looking at my eyelashes anyway
the thing about it is that
I don't know I like the way the
eyelashes look because it does actually
like give you a whole other
appearance really yeah the thing is
there's a very there's a big difference
between producing video Yeah and and
streaming right streaming is a lot more
yeah
um uh we called field expedient well
yeah like I said after a couple of yeah
after a couple of times I was just kind
of like yeah this is just too much
because I need something I can wear that
I can like move around in Freely that's
not gonna be like catching on everything
you have to be it it's it's theater it
is still theater you know I uh you know
like for those who don't know me I did
have some
me and grafters we went to Little
Theater school together we were kid it
is it is it is it's theater what you're
doing if you're doing it right
um
and just like any other theater like
black box theater
you could be asked to do any role or
anything at any time there's no
preparation just whatever that customer
wants you can he says can you guys do
this and this and I want to see this and
you're negotiating you're going yeah we
can do that we can do that so what
you're wearing may not be
suitable for what they're talking about
you have to wear things that are very
basic
they have to look good
they have to be you know uh what what
the customers you know something that
will attract a customer but it can't be
over complicated
and uh because you never know exactly
what they're going to ask you
and you can say you know and it's not
anything crazy it's just that yeah we
can do that but I just can't do that
right now I don't have the right shoes
on you know it has to be something like
that you know it's a lot like theater
yeah it and it's better especially if
we're going to be streaming for a long
time it's better to just have something
like that you're kind of comfortable in
because you do have to kind of move
around a lot and like you said you don't
really know what nobody asked for
anything like insane or it's usually
like along the same lines of [__] yeah
but
you never know every now and then
somebody gives you a curveball but yeah
and it's not something you wouldn't do
it's just you didn't think of that yeah
and you're just like oh [__] maybe yeah
we've been asked to do [__] and we're
like no we're not gonna do that
well like I said that's kind of the nice
thing about it is that you don't really
have to do anything you don't want to do
like people can come in and ask hey you
want to do you do this and you can just
be like nah like if you don't want to do
it they can just go someplace else and
like there's thousands of other people
on there the most common thing that the
most common thing that you got to say no
to is to ask for anal stuff yeah that
takes a lot of preparation and [__]
the thing yeah it's like I'm not I'm not
yeah and they're talking about a [__]
five minute show that you're gonna make
[__] you know
seven eight bucks off of in three
minutes or something or five minutes
some
you don't want to get involved in some
[__] [__] like that
for that amount of money
I mean if we were going to be on yeah if
we were going to be on for like hours
yeah and we knew that like a gold show
was coming right like I feel like that
would be something for that like because
then you'd know
what you were gonna do and you would be
all prepared for it and [__] like that I
feel like that but this this thing where
it's just like hey can you pop into this
room for like five minutes yeah and just
tear yourself off with this and just do
that I'm like yeah
like I said and maybe they could pass up
on that and take somebody that's asked
for something a lot easier this yeah
because most people ask for just like
easy [__] yeah they just want to see
your tits or they just want to see me
like you know when somebody's blowing
blowing you or whatever yeah it's like
and that's easy I guess you know I can
do that like right we can do that all
day long right some of the [__] they ask
for is would be easy to fake yeah some
of it they they they're like can you do
doggy from this position this and that
just for a few minutes and like and you
and the way the dude [__] asked for
that
I knew that he knew the deal that we
would fake it yeah he just wants some
jerk off to yeah that's what I mean
that's how it is I don't think so you're
like yeah okay like there's like that
wasn't real yeah they don't care if it's
real they don't care they don't care if
it's real or not they just wanna because
he specified the camera angle and
everything so he was he's he's coding to
be he's sending me the [__] secret
Guy Code you don't actually have to get
in you just want to see this [__]
happening you know what I mean okay well
he just wanted to see it from my like
from from from the front like from from
my face and like right he knew that that
was an easy order yeah that other
couples can do that at the drop of a hat
right because you know it's not me
sitting around [__] 10 minutes trying
to get ready for this [__] five
minute show hold on I'll be back in a
second I gotta go [__] fluff it's
gonna take me and then okay I'm ready I
can do it now although the nice thing
about what we started doing because the
first time the first few seconds we
streamed we actually tried to because we
wanted to like move the background so we
had a different background of this show
and blah blah blah so we started doing
that so we were kind of just like
sitting on the floor
and then that was kind of a pain and
then finally Tom was like you know why
don't we just leave the laptop where it
is yeah like um just like this just like
this it's like much easier and then like
if we have to we can push the chairs
back and like people can still see us
like back in the room and I was just
like yeah duh it's like and it's better
than like crawling around the floor
which is really uncomfortable so we
still want this but the but the nice
thing about it is that now it's like the
camera angle we can do all kind of stuff
like underneath the yeah and and yeah as
long as you're not you can be doing
stuff it's just that you can't show any
of that like in public you know what I
mean but you can like hint that you're
doing that you can tell that you're
doing it and you can tell them that
you're doing it and you can be doing it
as long as nobody as long as it's not
showing up on camera so we started doing
that and that does seem to like people
seem to like that because yeah because
then you can be like hey if you go
private you can see what we're doing you
know what I mean so then you can do that
right that works because you know
[__] I've already got the [__]
motor running man [__] you know what
I mean I'm like man
I can guys are coming in hey what's up
is this you know what's up
if I could go ahead and hit that [__]
go private button you you know we're
ready to go he's like all right you know
because he's a guy too it's like okay
you're ready to go all right let's go
yeah yeah
oh boy Mark M says Tom did you watch her
hear about the recent UFO hearings any
thoughts yeah you've been what you've
been watching those and the next
Dimension media also said I was going to
ask you that too all right I'm glad you
guys are asking good paranormal UFO
questions I'm gonna sit here I was I was
wondering if anybody was like gonna ask
him about you because I know he's been
watching I haven't been watching it but
I know he I've been watching Long Island
serial killers I actually haven't
watched
the hearings I've been listening to
the guy from the House of
Representatives the southern guy
who who made all these hearings happen
and I'm hearing some of the stuff but it
from what I've heard so far from the
guys that I listen to is that
it's real basic it's still kind of the
basic [__] that we know so far and
they're not really spilling any beans
they're not saying anything I don't know
what happened today I was I'm not on top
of it but by
yesterday they were hinting that they
had a lot of [__] but then everyone
taught they wouldn't want to talk about
it
what I think it is
I think it's a psyop I think it's a
psychological operation I think they're
yeah I think they're just teasing it's
[__] CIA
that's why I haven't been listening to
it because I'm like that yeah it's not
gonna imagine the CIA China the two the
two or three things going on right now
it's a CIA running interference for the
regime
one Ukraine's Got Its ass [__] handed
to it by the Russians just like I told
you that [__] was going to happen oh you
put all the Moonshine yeah yeah and it's
got It's got strawberries in it yeah
Ukraine's [__] toast all right
and uh that was not good for our uh for
our oligarch class that owns a lot of
Ukraine because now that's going to fall
up inside the Russian border and they
don't like that because they wanted to
run that place it's like a lawless
fiefdom
where they could uh get female sex
slaves and do [__] bioengineering in
there without the [__] watchful eye
of any kind of serious government
because the Ukrainian government a bunch
of Nazis really urbanistas which were
Nazis they they fought alongside of the
Third Reich
and somehow they were convinced the
American people that back in the Nazi
style government was a good thing
because their their leader is Jewish you
know this is [__] ridiculous it's all
CIA [__]
so they want to distract from
Ukraine's getting ready to [__]
collapse all right any moment now
um they want to hide from that they want
to hide from the hunter Biden [__]
thing and uh the barisma thing with uh
with with Biden so it's a distraction
from that
it's also a distraction there was
another one thing that that they were
distracted I forgot what it was I was on
tip of my tongue
it's another thing that's going on that
they don't
there's money market problems I think
what would now what was it but that was
the main ones
they're just trying to
wrestle attention away from the bad [__]
that's happening
and they're trying to uh
titillate the population with uh aliens
now what they could do
because the Ukraine thing fell through
they could come back and say we're going
to be attacked by aliens soon
I don't think the American public would
buy it though
stupid
I don't know but they are the CIA is
that crazy there there is uh
um there there were all these kind of
things in uh Marxist Doctrine too that
said that you could bring about a one
world [__] communist government if
you were being attacked by aliens and if
you could fake an alien attack you could
get people on that and pandemics and all
kinds of the [__] that's all happened
recently so I don't believe it I don't
believe it I don't believe it I don't
think they uh
I don't think they have any kind of
extraterrestrial craft
they evidently said they had biologics
I don't know what a biologic is I guess
it's like a biolog biological material
that could be anything that could be
bacteria you don't know what they're
talking about there
um
but I don't think they have anything
no it doesn't mean I don't think
extraterrestrials are being seen
some of those Air Force sightings yeah I
believe that yeah they saw some [__]
[__] cubes with spheres inside of
them and clear the jet past them
um the tic-tac-toe they're the
tic-tac-toe the Tic Tac UFO I call it a
tic-tac-toe I'm gonna call it a
tic-tac-toe from here on out I mean you
didn't mean to but yeah but now you kind
of have to leave
the Tic Tac UFO sighting yeah
but I don't think they know anything
well like I said it's just they're
probably it's probably just like
anything else it's like well you know
we're the UFO guys and we kind of just
want to like keep our brand in the
public eye so it's like every now and
then we kind of have to come out and be
like hey for real this time we have like
alien [__] but it's like
like I said they never did in the past
in the past
um the intelligence agencies have used
UFO stories to hide
um
secret programs well see that's I don't
even know if that works anymore because
they've done it so many times right so
now it's like every time they come out
like for real we have like UFO [__]
everybody's like no you don't shut up
yeah
[Laughter]
so they might just be using it now just
to [__] kind of like
try to distract from other things that
have happened like distracting from
Ukraine
well like I said I don't know if that
kind of [__] works anymore because
especially not UFO stuff no because I
feel like really
I don't think as many people are that
interested in UFOs look all you gotta do
is they think that there are all you got
to do is look at the regime on the right
or the left Republicans and Democrats
look at them they're old all right
they're old failing Boomers
Diane Feinstein can't barely talk the
president can't very we can't barely
talk well neither can you Tom I can
barely talk they're [__] they're
[__] up they're just they're crusty
old Boomers
live in a fantasy trying to keep a dying
machine running
and um
they don't know the outside ruled very
well because they don't use internet
they don't live normal lives like us
they don't live a modern life either
they probably still think people watch
TV which some people do as a [__] go
down to the damn Oasis and them all
bikers watching television they don't
what the [__] it's like going back to
so they think these old tricks will
still work
that's how out of date they are they're
just extremely uncool all of them
and um
their power is fading
because they can no longer control
narrative
used to be that you could Channel all
the information through [__] four
Network television networks and you can
control the minds of people the opinions
of people
and that and it kept the the ruling
class in charge in power and that's all
Fading
here's the thing these government people
just talked about
these Republicans and Democrats
sometimes people in Washington DC that
is not the ruling class that's the
servant class
okay those are the hired employees of
the of the real ruling class or a bunch
of oligarchs
people that trying to call you know
create monopolies and
[__] uh you know real rich people
people that [__] own things outside
the United States and they own things in
other countries and in Europe and
real rich people not these fake rich
people
Zach says Hey [__] I'm late
I mean not that late we've only been on
for an hour and a half uh James says
interdimensional life forms I don't
think these beings are from outer space
they have the ability to phase in and
out of our visible spectrum of light
which is why it looks like they just
disappear Into Thin Air
I mean interdimensional beings does not
sound that
out there to me I don't know if they
exist but
maybe I don't know interdimensional
would still be extraterrestrial that's
the same thing well
and here's and here's something I don't
know I think that's there's a fine
distinction there
not not from this planet it's another
planet that they're coming from well
maybe they're not maybe they're from an
alternate version of this that would
still be another planet
yeah there would still be another planet
it's in another dimension you want to be
dancing yeah it's still another planet
but here's the thing you could go back
to Star Trek and look at the [__]
warp drive with the [__] USS
Enterprise right that's extra
dimensional also because they're in a
warp bubble outside of space
true okay
they're going faster than the speed of
light which can't be done in normal time
space right they're coming out of it and
they're in they're in a warp bubble
right which is they're breaking the
[__] light barrier by doing that so
that's still that's the kind of
Technology involved in wormholing or
teleporting basically you know
it's all that same thing so
interdimensional doesn't mean anything
extra dimensional doesn't mean these
terms don't mean anything really they're
just things that they're saying
it's cheap to say [__] you know and
that's what they're just saying things
you know until they show you something
and some kind of sample or a body or or
a ship well see that's what I'm waiting
for yeah that's why whenever somebody
says something somewhere about it's like
oh they're having New Revelations about
UFOs and stuff I'm like yawn
because they're never gonna show you
yeah anything substantive so I'm just
like like I said I'm just gonna go read
about some serial killers so the whole
actually
[__] extra dimensional that that that's
that's also more things that they just
say
because if they're extra if they're
extraterrestrial they're from another
star system
that means they try that means that
they're [__] traveling fast distances
within a reasonable amount of time
there's no way to do that at the speed
of light
speed of light's too slow
so they have to be going
faster than the speed of light in Star
wars Star Trek terminology they're going
transwarp or high level Warp
which means that they're
bending Dimensions they're bending space
that's you know so that's so you could
say they were extra dimensional also
because they're they're not traveling
that actual distance not within
three-dimensional space
because there's a speed limit the speed
of light
on the way to break it is go to another
dimension
doesn't mean you're not extraterrestrial
though you have to be extraterrestrial
it's interdimensional doesn't mean
anything you made me just think of my
high school physics class where like the
guy had the the teacher had that sign
that said like it's you know
Intergalactic speed limit like speedless
yeah like no yeah it was fun it was
funnier than I'm making it yeah if
you're within three-dimensional space
you can't go any faster than light
it's more than it's an infinite amount
of energy to accelerate even a small
Mass to that speed
so that means it's not possible
not inside Space you have to leave space
to do that that's what warped was about
warp drive
it's moving but it's not moving inside
Space it's moving the space that it's
occupying
it's moving that space through space
which I I can't explain it James says
other dimensions exist like layers of
cake they exist along with us but
because they exist outside of our light
spectrum like I said it's why we can't
see them animals have the ability to see
more of the spectrum than we do that's
true like some animals can see
ultraviolet some can infrared and like
other things that we cannot see that's
not in our visual light spectrum it's
always kind of like fascinated me when I
was growing the thing is though is that
when you're talking about
extra dimensional stuff you're talking
about higher dimensions
what you're talking about with higher
Dimensions is kind of like the idea of
the Tesseract or a three-dimensional
object that kind of casts a shadow and
it casts a shadow into a into an
adjacent Dimension you can't live over
there it's just a side to a physical
object that you're not aware of
because you can't access it
so other dimensions don't mean anything
other dimensions a a higher Dimension
even if it's there you couldn't be able
to detect it
and it and it is already having the
influence on us that it has you might be
able to jump through space by going into
a higher Dimension and coming down which
is might be how an alien would do it
you could cover a lot of distance
without actually traveling the distance
kind of like out of dude
but you wouldn't be impressed if you saw
that higher Dimension and it probably
would just be a single point probably
wouldn't have any
length depth or width to it
it's a place where this place touches
that place and all of these places in
this universe touch that place
you understand what how about yeah yeah
okay so it's going to be something like
that
when you're talking about
parallel universes that's different
that's not another dimension
it's just that
in this universe I turned right in
Another Universe I turned left
they both exist
okay
but but they're separate from each other
they can't interact maybe a year from
now that the me that turned left can
somehow contact me but I don't think any
of that would work either you'd see it
happen all the time
I always found that concept fascinating
though and there's there's been like
some good uh movies actually that
explored that concept of like if
essentially like infinite versions of
this reality with slight alterations
um like if you haven't seen the movie
coherence you should really see that but
because it's it's
um
a story that takes that premise but they
did it like low budget they just shot it
in one house and everything like that
but like the implications of the idea
behind it were like really really well
done and it was kind of the thing where
there was
essentially like um infinite universes
where there were just like slight
variations of like this one Universe you
know what I mean and they were kind of
like freaking out because they were like
different versions of everybody yeah I
tell you I can tell you this much though
if that's happening
that it every moment there are other
things that could have that everything
spins right yeah if you were to go in
one of those other universes that you
weren't supposed to be you wouldn't even
know you wouldn't notice the difference
probably not because it would just seem
like a normal chain of event for you so
if there are parallel universes of this
universe maybe you're going in and out
of them all the time
right you wouldn't be aware of it and if
you wouldn't be and if somebody
artificially made you aware of it it
wouldn't make any difference
yeah in this universe I made a hundred
dollars and the other Universe I made
105.
you know it wouldn't make any any
relative it wouldn't make any difference
wouldn't be like something out of a damn
Stephen King novel where there's demons
you know and [__] you know it
wouldn't be here at school it wouldn't
be that fun it wouldn't be that fun
it'd probably be like really cool yeah
you wouldn't know they would all all the
universes would be real similar well
it's like in this universe I had tacos
for lunch in that Universe I had a ham
sandwich exactly
[Laughter]
Zach has finally arrived and said so I
went to the bath house again the other
day oh [__] the gay bath house and I
think I'm gonna have to make an
appointment with the cootie Clinic here
soon no Shaq what yeah you do I mean I
can imagine what you probably did but
I'm just like wondering why you think
you have some kind of um
Affliction you didn't shave before you
went or remember
crabs get up in you
Tammy says in what Universe does Tom get
picked
Tammy wants to see that video Tammy
wants to see
that we'll see it Tom it's just gonna
cost
them I got it if anything's [__] like if
any [__] like that happens if I would
videotape that [__] it'd be worth a lot
of money
but yeah but I had to get paper that's
like [__] gold right there we're
talking motorcycle money
new motorcycle
[Laughter]
that kind of money but see everybody has
a price though
everybody has a price everybody has a
price although I'm gonna say there are
probably some [__] there's probably some
[__] that I would not do for any price
and I'm not talking about necessarily
sexual things because yeah but I'm
talking about like other [__]
you know what I mean like if somebody
asked me to do like some really horrible
like have you ever seen the movie like
would you rather did you guys see that
movie where uh Jeffrey Combs was like
Jeffrey Combs was in it so Jeffrey Combs
was uh this super super rich guy and he
was making all these people like do
crazy [__] for
uh for money
and some of that [__] in there if I had
the choice I would not do it for any
amount of money
I said did you ever see that movie would
you rather no
where Jeffrey Jeffrey Combs was in it
you might like it actually Jeffrey Combs
was in it and he played this Rich dude
where it was like a game kind of thing
where he was like offering money for
like crazy [__] you know what I mean
like telling people to do crazy [__] and
I said most of the stuff in that movie
and I would not do for any amount of
money
so I I can think of a lot of things that
I wouldn't do for any amount of money to
be honest I mean it'd be nice to have
that amount of money that's for sure but
be easy to um some of the [__] would be
like that you wouldn't do for money yeah
um but when you start confining it to
sexual stuff you would do for money
that's a lot that's a lot more realistic
because you're not asking somebody to
kill somebody else that's what I'm
saying yeah like sexual stuff getting
your hand off first right yeah okay yeah
no that's what I'm saying it's sexual
stuff is stuff that you could do yeah
it's just would you and right and then
there's probably most [__] depending on
the amount I probably would yeah now
what if it was to be videotaped and sold
afterwards it would depend on what it
was depend on what it was right most of
the time most of the time depending on
what it was I probably wouldn't care
right I probably would have cared when I
was younger but now that I'm the age
that I am doesn't matter I don't really
give a [__] anymore we're talking we
were talking about that earlier so
in another show
people
they were asking us about some of the
[__] that we're doing you know
stream making video
and I would say I would not recommend
this for everybody
especially not a young person that has
like yeah I mean if they want to do it
I'm not going to tell people what to do
if they're an adult you know what I mean
but I'm just saying if they came to me
for advice specifically yeah
um probably if you're younger yeah like
if you're just in your 20s or something
like that
um I don't know if I would necessarily
advise it but like I said I'm not gonna
stop you
because you're an adult but I'm just
saying that it might like bite you in
the ass later on yeah yeah that's all
and it also depends on what it is
that too if you're going to do
mainstream
mainstream [__] uh
Studio level porn
you're in your 20s it's the [__] that
they have those girls do and the amount
of [__] dudes that run through them
and
that's really going to affect your
relationships all right and it young
people need to be having relationships
and having kids in their 20s you know
what I mean women if they want to have
kids you should really ideally have kids
in your 20s while you're young and you
have a lot of energy to raise the kid
and then when the kid's old enough going
on their own you're still young enough
to [__] do whatever the hell you want
then you can be liberated and
independent
you know that is one of the plus sides
of having kids yeah yeah
you're still young when they grow up and
get the [__] out your house
a lot of the [__] a lot of the [__] tell
girls here in the United States and the
Western world is backwards
they tell them they should sell their
souls off to these [__] soul-crushing
careers in an office at an early age
the [__] no
no
what really women should do is have kids
young I mean if they want them yeah I
never have them yeah that way you shake
that kid out quick and then you snap
back and then you're [__] you're an
adult
and by the time you're 30 you're still
[__] young and the kids now pretty
grown it's what you know a kid might be
well by the time you're 40 the kid's
like 20 years old yeah right away at
college right and you're still
relatively right now
for girl jumps [__] knee deep into
[__] Studio porn she's probably also
jumping in knee deep into sugar in and
or sugar daddy and then [__]
escorting
your selection of Mates is gonna [__]
dwindle down to only a certain kind of
guy
and it may not be the kind of guy you
want
all right so I wouldn't recommend I
don't recommend these adult careers to
young women
for a mature woman who's already lived
her life she knows who she is she's got
a strong uh sense of self and identity
you know what I mean so she can do all
this role playing and all this [__]
entertainment she's already had her kids
they're over she's already had like a
life she's already had experiences she's
already had something of a career she's
already have she's already done all that
so it's just kind of like if you know if
later on like oh some boss finds out oh
my God you did porn it's just like [__]
you I'm 45. yeah what are you gonna do
to me yeah you know I don't care right
so yeah
that's like I said I think that is the
single best thing about getting older
yes you don't give a [__] about older
people are a lot more a lot Freer
from consequences because when you get
nothing's long-term really anymore
everything is kind of short term well
yeah you're just thinking wow I might
only live like another 20 or 30 years at
this point yeah and it goes by fast so
right and like yeah and the older you
get like the faster [__] goes by right
yeah so it's like you don't really you
don't care as much you don't care as
much anymore and also things don't
affect you as much because you know who
you are
yeah you don't give it you don't give as
much of a [__] about what other people
think of you yeah and if say you were to
do something that is not really all that
kosher and some [__] porn scene that
is not who you are you know who you are
that's just something you did
it didn't really affect well the way
that I think about it is that like you
know the we make the videos and we're on
the stream and stuff like that and I was
just like well that's just it doesn't
bother me I guess because it's just like
well that's just [__] that we'd be doing
anyway like most of it if it wasn't on
film or anything like that so it's just
like oh we're just filming it but and a
lot of people do that nowadays so it's
like I'm not really that concerned a lot
of the [__] we and some of the [__] that
we've done at least on stream mate was
for a client
and it was just totally role playing you
know like I'm slapping her and [__] like
that you know what I mean [__]
because that's what the customer wanted
yeah it was within safety reasons and
yeah I'm not into that [__] he didn't
hurt me yeah and I'm not into that [__]
that didn't do anything to me that
didn't change me it didn't change her
because it was it was just some [__]
we did well and he asked me but he's
like is that okay like are you okay with
that and I was just like yeah I just
don't knock my head off but you know
what I mean yeah it's all right I have a
high pain tolerance yeah
you know it's like doing pro wrestling
yeah it was kind of like that's yeah it
was kind of like that yeah
and the dude seemed to enjoy it so like
I said things gotta be back you know
like you didn't hurt me so it's just
kind of like so he got us like it made
good noises and stuff so he did a good
job I cut my hand like that yeah so it
makes it like a big happen yeah yeah
yeah but it didn't really he wanted me
to talk talk me to her you know
[Laughter]
roughing her up no it is kind of weird
how how many dudes are into that though
yeah that is kind of that is kind of
weird yeah like how they want to see
like what happens like a chick get
roughed up and yeah abused yeah like
verbally abused yeah but I've actually
no girls that liked that though yeah
some girls do yeah I'm just saying but
it's interesting pull her hair rough
them up
um talk talk bad I like that sometimes
but sometimes I'm not in the mood for
that you know what I mean yeah well
sometimes you just want [__] to be
comfortable and easy get it over with
well it's not so much getting it over
with It's just sometimes you I don't
know sometimes you're not in the mood
for that you know yeah sometimes you are
but sometimes not yeah it's all like in
how you feel that day yeah well some of
it had to do with [__] being real
young too
yeah you're young it's easier to get
easier to [__]
excitement is a lot more effective on
you
yeah maybe that's what it has a lot to
do with it
I guess Victor says hey I made it what's
up hey welcome Victor
what turned you gay this time Vic we
haven't talked we don't know he just got
here and so we don't know like what what
have we been talking about that might
have made him gay today I don't know a
boy [__] aliens catching
interdimensional aliens catching cooties
in the mail in the bath house
that [__] cooties in the bathroom so
could that somehow made you guess
he heard about it and it flipped him gay
yeah Zach says uh [__] a slight tingle
every once in a while at the end of
something because for concern I don't
know man I don't know
have you ever experienced that time no
after going to the after going to the
bath house no
never been to a bath house I know I find
that hard to believe why would I go to a
bathroom
[__] bad
you know you love it you know you love
it I do why would I love it I don't know
me exactly like I said I'm just Mama go
ahead if I'm gonna have a bath if I have
a gay bath that's gonna be me and Zach
he's another game
okay
bath is me and Zach up at the [__]
up on the penthouse of the [__]
Dunes hotel and [__]
Las Vegas there you go we're up in the
penthouse in the [__] hot tub in a
heart-shaped tub I feel like it needs to
be a bubble bath we got a gap of Friday
[__] playing
damn I don't even get all that no [__]
no this is gay gay if it's gay it's got
to be a certain way I got a boa on I got
a feather boa and I'm in the hot tub
with a feather boa
camera Cruise there
all right yeah I'm liking the scenario
yeah I got Zach licking the bottom of my
feet can I watch her yeah okay yeah yeah
are you gonna be weirded out if I'm in
there or do I have to be behind like too
much you can come in and fluff
everything just wondering yeah now you'd
be there okay I didn't know if you can
wear it out
[Laughter]
while you're having your gay bath
experience don't don't use Mr Bubble
though so you're what you're trying to
say is that if you if you if you and
it's not it's now you're afraid that it
won't be gay enough
there's too much estrogen well that's
what I mean I might interfere okay
so I might have to like watch it from
afar like I said you might be like like
a two-way mirror or something I can
watch it from behind that
see this is this is the thing okay
Jen Jen is talking all this [__] trying
to act like she's all bashful when her
Ultimate Fantasy was to see me and David
Bowie
getting it on and David Bowie in in damn
jareth costume from [__] labyrinth in
those pants but yeah he had to be
wearing those pants and that hair too
that hair it would be good but I mean
any any of his looks would be fine any
of his looks would be fine but I'm just
I'm not picky
well it's not gonna happen now is he
because he died
Tim says Tom gonna there's that read the
comments the [__] Tom is gonna borrow
your alien until dildo yeah
he might be using it when I'm not here I
don't know no
in your dreams my alien dildo yeah
Zach's saying something there what's he
saying fun fact the place I went to used
to have a Jacuzzi but they took it out
because water was crawling with all the
STDs
the water was yeah they're like we
tested the water and every single STD
including a few that we haven't
identified yet are swimming around
chlorine didn't kill all that so well
that's the thing maybe these were like
super bugs that were like impervious to
chlorine
yeah they were like you know
so Zach tell us about super chlamydia
Zach tell us about the bath house
[__] what it was like when you went
there see that's crazy because I mean I
guess like on an intellectual level I
knew that there was still bath houses
around but I kind of felt like that was
more I don't know I just felt like that
was more like a 70s and 80s thing
um
I don't know and it's like I knew that
they were still around but I didn't know
if they were still like widespread to
any extent because I know like in the
70s they had them [__] everywhere but
so I didn't really know how like [__]
how
many of them were still around you know
I guess they never went anywhere
James says it's not the same but a
flavored condom would help with stuff in
the future
holy [__] one of the funniest things I
don't know why that's well I know why it
reminded me of it
I was in the UK
uh many years ago probably
15 20 years ago something like that now
and you know how in the train stations
like in the bathrooms of the train
stations in the UK they always have like
condom machines right
um they had some flavored condoms some
of the flavors were like normal I guess
as as much as a condom flavor could be
normal it's just like strawberry and
[__] like that which you know that's not
that crazy but then
there was
curry flavor Curry flavored condoms
and I was like
I kind of want to buy these I'm like I'm
sure they taste terrible but
I was like the flavor stuff that they
put on those it's like that can't be
chemically
I mean I'm sure that would give you all
kind of infections
yeah what the [__] Curry that's what I
said that's what I said
Curry flavored condoms
only in Britain seriously in a in a
British train station
strawberry condom flavor
um like one other flavor that was like
kind of normal like it's like vanilla or
something and then like the one next to
it was Curry and I'm like no [__] way
I should have taken a picture of it
what kind of Curry see I don't know it
was just like generic Curry it was just
like curry flavor and I was like so I
guess it must have just I was like what
did they just dust it with curry powder
it must have been terrible
yeah I was like I kind of wanted to get
one just out of curiosity but it's like
I'm sure it's like tastes awful
although wouldn't it be funny if it was
like if you got one and it was like
delicious it tasted just Zach's going on
about YouTube and [__]
hoping it's just a UTI well I just well
you can read it right just a UTI it's
like those [__] suck I just I
I don't get them so much in like anymore
but I used to get them a lot
like probably like once or twice a year
and they are not fun like a few times I
had to
go to the CVS clinic to get the [__]
antibiotics actually one time probably
like 20 years ago I got one
um that was really bad and then I didn't
have any money to go to get antibiotics
so I was just like well maybe it'll go
away on its own spoiler alert it did it
and it actually went to my kidneys and
gave me a kidney infection which was
probably the most painful thing that
I've ever experienced and I ended up
having to go to the emergency room so
that was fun
so don't ignore UTIs you guys I'm just
saying don't don't be like me because I
did that and that was probably the worst
pain I think that's funny that Tammy
remembers the alien dildo
well you show it all the time so no I
didn't show it all the time well I mean
you showed it a few times okay
go grab that [__] again
right here yeah show that to him we got
all the decks right here show that to
Tammy I want to tell her something you
want to tell her something yeah okay
that's the alien show that show that to
Tammy good show give her a good view of
that [__] it's actually much greener
than it looks on camera because the
white the whites is kind of like washing
it out yeah it's actually like neon
green right it's neon green
Tammy that's what you need right there
okay that [__] has got all kinds of
ridges on it it gets fatter at certain
parts of it all right got that off of uh
um this will tear you up girl you need
that not as much as the other one not as
much as the other one but that that is
um we got that off of Amazon
and it looks like an extraterrestrial I
think I got it on Sheen actually it
looks like an hour we did it no okay no
that was not Sheen it all kind of looks
like an extraterrestrial maggot as well
yeah it looks like a it looks like an
insect
it's alien it's not human yeah yeah
Tammy said all the time I've seen it
three times that's right yeah you and
your I've just shown it once I'm like no
it's been several times
that burned in her mind though that just
go ahead and go ahead and get it Tammy
it's uncut too
yeah see it's not it just reminds me
it's very Crone and Bergen I think
that's what I like about it like I like
like I said I kind of like
I like I like the ones that look
interesting they're like interesting
colors or look like Monsters or
something like that like I said they're
not always so super fun to use
like for their intended purpose show
them the worst one but well yeah I mean
we showed this one a bunch of times too
I love that this is my favorite the look
of this one is my favorite but like I
said using it for its intent and purpose
is like super not fun you know what this
kind of reminds me of it's
do you remember back in
when was this the 80s or the 90s
remember like at Spencer's and
um and uh Hallmark and [__] like that
they used to have like those fancy
candles yeah that were all like swirly
and like that you know they carved out
and they were like I had one that was
like black and white and it was really
pretty
um this kind of reminds me of that you
know what I mean yeah but also like a
lovecraftian yeah tentacle type
situation James talking about Bad Dragon
yeah these are like knock off bad drag
it's a real bad dragon is expensive
they're expensive those things are
[__] super expensive so there's so
now there's like a whole industry of
like knockoff ones yeah that are much
cheaper I don't even remember how much
this one was it wasn't it wasn't much
this one was what
about 30. I think it was 30 yeah which
like I said is pretty it's pretty cheap
give them a good side view of it yeah
get your hand out of the way
well I gotta hold it dummy hold it from
the back and now they can't see okay
well I'm clearly doing it wrong I bet
that's what yeah everybody really wants
to see the bottom of the [__]
right there I've seen that thing in
action John Gore said very big at head
shops those candles were yeah I remember
those I had one somebody gave it to me
like I used to think they were really
cool looking you know what I mean I'm
sure they still have them but
but they were all like um carved and
swirly and [__] like that so it kind of
like reminds me of this is Zach's
telling a story about going to the bath
house let me see
uh he's got chemicals from the pool yeah
well
uh also that place is kind of a fire
hazard super dark mirrors everywhere
kind of set up what okay hoping it's
just okay yeah okay
um we're gonna set up like a maze I
walked into several walls and almost
fell down the stairs a few times yeah I
do that kind of [__] too don't feel bad
was it just a little while dudes in
there and the steam bath at this place
is like walking into a horror movie It's
Dark and foggy if you have glasses and
that bad night vision Good Luck Good
Luck not running into anyone or anything
why is a nice boy like you going into
these dirty places man well I don't
understand it I don't understand it Zach
why wouldn't you okay I guess so it's
gonna go down there and just hand
himself over to those heathens
just they're gonna take care of his
[__] flesh and [__] mortify your
[__] flesh dude okay
Tammy said let Tommy show you how to
hold a dildo the right way right and
then he and then he and then he just
showed like the bottom of it like what
the [__]
that's not what happened
okay listen to her Zach says who said I
was a nice boy I said that yeah I said
that [__] but you're probably wrong
because
[__] a [__]
he's like yeah yeah
what's wrong with [__] he's gonna be
going down there go down there and all
you're gonna run into Rob Halford
I'm still gonna get that I'm gonna get
that Rob Halford on a biography God damn
it we saw that we were at the bookstore
the other day getting some coffee and I
was like look Tom they have like Rob
Halford as an autobiography I kind of
want to read it every time these uh gay
rock stars die they got to make a movie
about him if he dies they better make a
[__] Rob Halford movie I'm honestly
I'm probably good why haven't they made
one up tonight it's probably good
he strikes me as an interesting dude
that's what I mean I kind of want I kind
of want to read that the lyrics Judas
Priest lyrics are the [__] greatest
especially the 70s stuff
70s lyrics were really good like sinner
dissonant aggressor and [__]
Tyrant and
Exciter great songs he's just [__]
I'd have contact him actually I got him
on I got him on [__] Instagram he
probably talked to me
you think probably
I mean unless he gets I'll send him a
dick pic
oh God
[Laughter]
like every woman in the world just
rolled their eyes like Jesus [__]
Christ I I
some questions I want to ask him well
yeah I mean go for it I want to ask him
the song sinner
is he talking about Mars the God of War
that's like pretty sure he's talking
about Mars
that Mars is the center but if you guys
don't know the song [__] then you
wouldn't know what I'm talking about but
it's a great it's a great song I like I
actually showed that song to Zach he
goes yeah it's pretty good
especially for 70s [__] metal song
Oracle said I really did just roll my
eyes as Jenny was saying that about
setting a dick yeah yeah because I said
every woman in the world is like oh
Jesus
he's a man no
yeah men might see a difference yeah
that's the thing it's like I'm always
kind of like well I know why like
intellectually I know why dudes send
dick pics yeah but it's just like to
women it makes absolutely no sense it's
like why the [__] would you do that like
I'm just I think to a gay man make total
sense he's like yeah well yeah to a gay
man yeah that's good but like to a woman
you're like uh
uh why would you send me that I don't
know you and it's like it's just some
distant body part that you're sending me
and it's kind of like threatening and
obnoxious afterwards I say by the way it
wasn't my dick it was just a picture of
a dick today
hahaha
see now that would be kind of funny
that would be kind of funny
it'd be actually funnier if you probably
sound like a [__] no I actually got
some questions I got some questions for
Rob I hadn't thought about I got him on
Instagram
but I'm gonna take time I'm gonna write
him a little letter okay yeah because
you know say man I was back in high
school listening to you man [__] and
some of these lyrics are tripping me out
and I I have some questions about some
of these lyrics I also wanted to know
there's a couple of lines in inside
[__] Raw Deal
what you're talking about going to Fire
Island all right going he said he made
the spike on around nine o'clock on a
Saturday all right this is a [__] gay
bondage club
and there's a couple lines I can't quite
make out what he's saying and I was
getting into a fight with some guys a
couple years back not really a fight but
discussing a couple years back on on a
YouTube video with that had that song
what he was actually saying
and I think he's saying and there he was
so mean and cruel
yeah but the other guys didn't had a
different interpretation what is it but
he's talking about leather daddies man
which is funny and being mean and cruel
is a good thing in the leather daddy
world so that's what it sounds like we
like that right yeah
but that's what's funny is I kind of
feel like back then well back then all
the straight dudes that were listening
to it didn't really get any of that
subjects no
I didn't figure that out until I was
like maybe a senior in high school
a lot of what he was talking about was
just going over my head
but by the time I was a senior I was
like oh okay yeah I know he's talking
about
you know I was vaguely aware that there
was a bondage scene in the in the gay
thing you know yeah
I didn't realize the heavy metal was
that closely related to it but no he was
it is this is a very fine line yeah it's
very funny to me because well
particularly in the 80s when I think
metal went more like cockroach kind of
yeah and got considerably Lamor and
became for girls really it yeah and it's
almost kind of like they were trying to
be like overtly Macho but I was just
kind of like yeah but they're wearing
their girlfriend's clothes though
literally
here was the dumb thing and even in
junior high I thought this was dumb yeah
because look I was into junior high I
was in junior high and I was real into
New Wave right
which you you say you had like in my
junior high school there were like two
contingents I mean other than like the
people that didn't get involved but all
the people that were like into music
subcultures you had all the new wave
people and the you know kind of punk
people and all those kind of people
which is the people I hung out with and
then you had like all the metal heads
and all the metal heads were kind of
more they weren't even in good [__] they
were into like you know like cockroach
kind of [__] and they were all kind of
like calling us
oh we were all Weenies and nerds and
[__] and everything like that and I'm
just like but you but they look like
women too though
like they're they're getting all over
like Boy George's case and like she's
like oh they're all gay I'm like look at
your [__] [__] you must be talking
about you must be talking about
Cinderella and Paul yeah they were all
into that kind of crap yeah just yeah
they were they were like I was like
that's just yeah it's Glam Rock and it's
not even good Glam Rock it's just shitty
Glam Rock they were kind of copying the
like the New York Dolls yeah big time
except the New York Dolls were like 100
times cooler yeah sorry well that was
the Lac yeah the Lac you know uh started
to go
very glammy looking
really I think it might have started
with Bon Jovi I think that's bonjo I
don't know if they were the first ones
to do it but they were and they weren't
the most
glammy of all of them no poison was yeah
someone I remember and white lion Motley
Crue went that way too didn't start even
though no I was gonna say even though
Molly cruise early [__] was kind of more
it was better yeah [__] that first
Motley Crew album actually kind of
looked like almost goth a lot of black
bondage type gear and it was kind of
gender bending kind of stuff and then
shadow of the devil came out that was
basically kiss a reboot of kiss that's
what James just said kiss and [__]
Pantera with Glam rocket yeah White
Snake Oracle points out yet yeah [__]
white snake
gotta hate it here I go again on my own
the White Snake terrible it's terrible
yes
which is a court they're talking about
Dick you know [__] white It's gotta
be
I kind of feel like all of that stuff
was so they don't call it [__] rock for
nothing yeah that's all they're talking
about yeah they knew though they knew
it's just that they but it's like it's
funny to me because fans didn't know
right a lot of their fans were like
these teenage boys that were like trying
to be like overly Macho and melee and
everything like that and I'm just like
yeah but y'all look more girly than
[__] Duran Duran does that's for sure
it depended on the band yeah it's not so
much Iron Maiden so what do you like
[__] on us for
[Laughter]
there was also there were also bands
like uh
and we're getting into [__] heavy
metal
there are also bands that didn't make it
that were kind of underground during
that time that were really good there
was a German one called accept I really
liked the set and they were kind of like
a German version of
Judas Priest but it was mixed with
Metallica they had a singer's name was
Udo Durkin Snyder and he was this little
short that is the germanous name that
I've ever heard yeah it was kind of this
short
dumpy kind of guy you know what I mean
he does not look like he was maybe five
one or five two or something and he was
real stocky he had a great voice though
I liked how he sounded it was
and there were a lot of bondage
kind of overtones to to some or
undertones to what they were doing
and it was funny because in that
particular bad
and this is back in like 1986 Maybe
I'm trying to remember what the name of
the song was I'm gonna bring the
bathroom real quick yeah
trying to remember what the name of the
song was you can sit in my chair but it
was the number
they were actually talking about
uh gender confusion about this uh guy in
high school he's being picked on because
he doesn't know if he's a boy or a girl
and it was the weirdest thing you know
what I mean [__] when you're
you know like in
10th grade or something and you're
hearing this and it's the first time
that subject's coming up but looking
back on it that was kind of um
ahead of its time
and it was happening in metal music
maybe somebody might know the exact name
of that song they might be able to look
it up because I'm sure the internet
knows about that song
but anyway years later I found out that
Udo and the guys from accept actually
didn't didn't really write those lyrics
Udo had a woman working for him who was
like a mega fan
and she had a lot she had a lot of their
touring and a lot of their behind the
scenes
Logistics and she was kind of like
support and everything and she wrote a
lot of those songs the lyrics to A lot
of the songs she wrote that song
I just thought it was uh kind of
kind of kind of weird in a certain way a
lot of people wouldn't think that heavy
metal would kind of have
I guess you could say they were kind of
like
heavy metal bands were the [__] uh
[__] where'd Jen go what okay there you
go oh [__]
what the [__] you can't be that you
wouldn't think or I wouldn't have
thought wouldn't have thought and I was
a kid back then living through it I
wouldn't have thought that metal music
was was the scene that was first
starting to discuss all that stuff
transgenderism
and I didn't well because like I said I
feel like a lot of and I don't think
this was necessarily coming from the
musicians I think it was coming from the
fan base more than anything I mean at
least from what I remember because the
fan base just seemed very very
overly
Macho or they were at least trying to
project being overly Macho which like I
said I think well I always feel like
people that feel the need to project
being like overly manly or overly Macho
that's always just kind of like masking
insecurity
that's what I'm saying and I I was there
man I thought that [__] was cool as [__]
you know what I mean uh but then later I
started getting into other other bands
really what got me out of metal was
girls
as soon as you start dating metal stops
making stops making sense
what started to make sense was more like
you too and [__]
um Duran Duran started to make a whole
hell of a lot more sets and Billy Idol
made more sense when you were when you
were dating and [__] but
I just thought it was I just thought it
was strange looking back on it that
that metal was
um
so socially Progressive compared to a
lot of the other metal that was going on
a lot of stuff that was going on yeah
just it it just the fans didn't weren't
didn't really they didn't really aware
of it right they wouldn't really seem to
well like he said a lot of the fan base
was teenage boys they were too young to
understand so I think they didn't really
like get all of the nuances of what they
were talking about which is
kind of true of a lot of genres yeah I
feel like a lot of stuff is going on in
the [__]
that and it was obvious that [__]
Ozzy Osbourne was talking about LSD and
out-of-body experiences and
smoking weed and drinking too much I
mean it was very obvious
but it wasn't obvious to a teenage boy
what Rob Halford was talking about yeah
I mean or what
Udo Durkin Snyder was talking about I
mean unless they were Iron Maiden was
talking about because that was kind of
written at our level yeah I mean that's
not my history well the thing about it
is that unless you were experiencing
that yourself like for example if you
were a teenage boy that was thinking
about like you know being transgender or
something like that then you would
probably get it like holy [__] he's
talking about like then you would
probably relate yeah but if you weren't
if you were just like had other concerns
or something like that it would probably
just like go over your head like you
would probably think they were talking
about something else I remembered I
remembered that accept song when I was a
kid and it made sense you know what I
mean I was just like well okay that that
that's what they're talking about and
from what I remembered about it it was
basically a don't worry about it song
like you know what I mean like yeah
they're picking on you but don't worry
about it
yeah it was that kind of because what
the hell do they yeah what the [__] do
they know is that kind of thing it's
like this is your life let me go get
some more eyes all right I wouldn't mind
a little bit of a refill it's Friday
night for Christ's sake
chagoras said metal was like Punk but
without the irony or self-awareness
yeah I mean it's hard because I do kind
of feel like Punk and metal are almost
kind of like I don't even want to say
their flip sides because they're very
very similar in a lot of ways
it's the music of
disaffection
um but like you said I think Punk had
that extra fill up of
just I don't know like you said it was
just it's more like an ironic
kind of [__] whereas metal was very
I don't want to say necessarily like
po-faced or earnest
because it depended on the band
but
I I do definitely feel like Punk was
more like taking the piss out of
themselves along with everything else
Zach says also R.I.P Sinead O'Connor
yeah that was um
have they said how she died I thought
the way that they were
framing it at least from the few
articles that I read
um did she commit suicide
I know her son did
last year year before when I don't
remember what it was
but I thought they were I thought that's
kind of what the implication was
yeah see that's what I thought too like
they don't come out and say that I know
they don't usually because they don't
they're still like a stigma about it but
I thought that that's what the wording
was hinting at were you talking about
Sinead O'Connor yeah what I thought
probably she had committed suicide
and they don't really say that because
like I said her son committed suicide
also like just last year and I know that
she was really [__] up about that well
she was always had mental problems I
think she did
um you know but
she kind of got like Done Dirty I feel
like
honestly I really I know everybody was
real into nothing compares to you which
was it was a print song but I had her I
don't know was it her first album
the [__] was that album called the line
in the Cobra that had mandinka on it I
bought that back in whenever it came out
87 88 I don't remember and man I used to
play that all the time that was a great
[__] album she had a great [__]
voice you know I mean she's a great
[__] voice and it was kind of sad
and honestly I know that like the one
thing everybody remembers about her is
her tearing up that picture of the Pope
on SNL
but I was kind of like man that was like
some ballsy [__] I did and I was upset
that everyone was like mad about her I'm
like who cares
like I said I'm an atheist I don't give
a [__] about any of that kind of stuff
so I was just kind of I just thought it
was kind of like I thought it was
amusing that everyone was so offended by
it
um you know back then but I don't
remember what year that happened
and then like she couldn't she literally
could not go anywhere after that like
without getting [__] booed
just because of that and I'm just like
who would have thought in this day and
age did anyone get that their panties in
a Twist about something stupid like that
but okay
people talk about people but getting
[__] outraged nowadays like back then
holy crap man
her career was pretty much ruined after
that who Shane O'Connor
tearing up the picture of the Pope oh
yeah and I was just like in the time she
did that I was like yeah all right
I was like I thought I saw the
interviews I thought that was pretty
cool that she did that I saw interviews
with her from that time though
she said that she was surrounded by a
bunch of people that were just having
her do things
to shock stuff you know what I mean
and she you know
she said she wouldn't have done that
normally
she uh like they were
somebody told her to [__] basically
protest the playing in the national
anthem before program that's one thing
she she was surrounded by
some people that were trying to get her
to misbehave because she would end up in
the newspaper too right well I guess
that works but like I said it also kind
of like ruined her career it ruined her
career which was a shame because she was
actually really she's real good yeah
real good like I said I had her what
what was was the line of the cover her
first album
because I had that one and it's [__]
great yeah I don't know if you haven't
listened to it it's great but what was
uh
while she was telling the story they
were showing pictures of the guy they
showed videos of the guy who was egging
her on and it was just another youngster
yeah you know I wasn't an older person
it's just another person in their 20s
really
they were just trying to
it was easy to get a lot of attention
back then they only had a few television
channels and MTV was a thing still
and uh if you did something outrageous
they put you on the news well the crazy
thing about that like I said is that
that happened how many years ago did
that happen it was a long time a long
time ago and Pete and when you noticed
today well yeah but it's like now when
you say that when you say Sinead
O'Connor that's like one of the main
things that people remember about her
like that [__] she did on SNL and that
was like [__] decades ago which is
crazy to me yeah and if you were to do
that today you wouldn't get any
attention at all that's what I mean
it'll probably people would be outraged
for like five minutes and then they'd
move on to the next thing if it was
honestly nobody would have seen it
because people don't watch that anymore
they got no viewers there's no those
those those venues are dead that mode of
[__] communication is dead well like
I said there's been like a YouTube star
or I mean people still get outraged
about stuff obviously but it's usually
like a smaller percentage of the
population you're not gonna get like the
whole entire country being outraged yeah
or something like you were about like
like you were about like the whole super
like the whole Super Bowl thing with
like Janet Jackson's nipple showing yeah
God forbid yeah it wasn't her nipple it
was a piece of jewelry around her nipple
I know it's like a pasty everyone's got
a nipple okay I think I think all that
was faked actually well I think uh I
think the outrage was faked also I think
the news media kept repeating how
outraged everybody was
and if they made a lot of money off of
that well some people must have fallen
for it and like thought they were
outraged about this year because I
remember everybody [__] talking about
it even though I could not they were
told to be outraged that's what I mean I
could not give a single [__] about that
yeah when you're just like it's a nipple
everyone's understanding sales and
propaganda not only did the television
show you something it told you how you
were supposed to feel about it
it did that but it was very subtle how
they did it and then they would repeat
they would use the same news they would
use the same corporate news uh media to
tell you what everybody else thought
about it even though they were the
source and because they are telling
everybody how everybody feels about it
they all go oh I guess that's how we
feel about it
I don't feel that way but I guess
everybody else feels that way
um there was a whole [__] book about
it what's it called manufacturing
consent I forgot the name of the guy who
wrote it didn't know you write that
might have been I think it might have
been known jobs manufacturing consent
the consent is always artificial and
that was the power that the news media
has and the regular media
it shows you something and tells you how
you think about it and how everybody
else thinks about it well luckily for me
they are the source I don't give a [__]
what anybody else thinks about anything
and it's the same [__] that that's
because who cares I don't know those
people it goes all the way back to
[__] fascist propaganda from [__]
Nazi Germany and [__] you know
they show you something and tell you how
you think about it and then they say
this is what everybody else thinks about
it you go oh I guess that's how we think
about it yeah that's it's mind control
that's why the CIA was so interested in
that well see that's why like I said
that's why I'm very glad that I'm just
genetically I'm just not a joiner uh and
I'm not a real
I'm not a person that gives much of a
[__] about what other people think about
things
um I'm usually like approach things like
how do I feel about this yeah without
really like caring that much about what
other people feel about it
anything that comes from a corporate
source of information is always to be
mistrusted always
because there's money behind it and it's
a message telling you how to feel about
something
and they're controlling what information
you have and then they're denying you
other information that you could have
but they're not going to talk about that
so everything is that's and it was done
through television for [__] what near
nearly 100 years well uh I guess it's
nearly 100 years 80 years now
I'm trying to think of good thing
television is dying when TV became
widespread I know it was an event well
TV was invented
in probably like the early 20th century
or maybe actually late 19th it was 30s
but I think it didn't really become
widespread until like the 40s television
was television was invented before World
War II it was in the late 20s early 30s
it's just that it didn't never got big
it's in proliferated right and when the
world when when the world wars happened
they put it all on hold
yeah because we were watching that
there's a really good and I think Oracle
actually
um recommended it
uh it was that History Channel series
what the hell is it called
the machines that made America something
like that or something like that there's
a whole series of them but yeah and it
just goes into and it goes into like all
this other goes into TV it goes into
like washing machines and it's
fascinating it's really really good and
I think they're like all on they might
I'll be all be on Hulu now actually
because we've been watching on them on
there John Gore said didn't the lead
singer of The Cranberries snuff herself
too yeah uh Dolores um Riordan she died
the bathtub from drinking but I think it
was an accident well I don't know if it
was an accident or it might have been
suicide I don't know well because
sometimes well that's what I mean
sometimes when people commit suicide
there's still kind of a stigma about it
and so like a lot of times they'll try
to like make it seem I guess they're
trying to preserve the person's dignity
in some way because there's oh well
accidentally but it's like is that
better I don't know I feel like it's
probably bad to like say that they
didn't kill themselves man she could
sing and she was cute I liked her she
was rad I liked her too I liked the
Cranberries
I mean that's [__]
I get it I mean Irish girl I mean I get
it I get why people do that yeah I do
but it's just kind of she drank like a
fish though she was just looking sure
she couldn't keep her nose out of it
um I think it was probably an accident
although who knows
that's what I mean it could have been an
accident but she was just kind of like I
don't give a [__] I think it might have
been that what it was she just drag
herself into a stupid and the damn
bathtub and died yeah and she wouldn't
care she didn't really care right
which that's really sad it's really sad
Oracle says um about Sinead O'Connor she
ripped up the Poke photo because she'd
witnessed clerical abuse no one believed
her back then which like I said is kind
of sad because I remember some people
coming out back then and talking about
the widespread
abuse that was going on in the Catholic
church and it was kind of I don't know
if it was necessarily like I don't know
if I would say it was ignored but I
think that a lot of people were just
kind of like sort of pushed it under the
rug kind of like they didn't really want
to talk about it like now everybody
knows about that [__] but back then not
so much I think they kind of thought but
so it went on for like years and years
to a you know to an extent we should
probably do a show about that although
that's like a huge topic
you'd probably have to concentrate just
like on one [__]
City to be honest like if you wanted to
like narrow it down because it's so
[__] widespread and then like for
years and years they had a thing where
it's like well we have all these priests
in this one
um diocese that are abusing all these
people but I said we'll just move them
to this other City it'll be fine well
get him out of our hair and that
happened a lot there was a case where uh
the Catholics
had us had a bunch of school girls
I guess they were for Wayward girls and
in the meantime they were pimping them
out to the police
yeah for that that none found out about
it and they killed her well that was um
yeah that was did we do every show I
remember writing about that that was
sister Kathy sesnick yeah
um yeah that was a Netflix series
pimping the school girls out to the cops
and local politicians I believe it yeah
now here's the thing you know that was a
big organization and they weren't highly
supervised and they had access to kids
it's only a matter of time before
there's something like that's going to
happen because I can if you have access
to kids the petos are going to try to
work their way into that system and over
time they got [__] real corrupt like
that
the average Catholic wouldn't approve of
any of that no of course not like I said
I'm not impugning the entire Catholic
religion because of that like I said I'm
not a fan of religion in general but I'm
just saying I would never impuge just
like a regular just on the street
Catholic just because of that I'm just
saying that it's like it's kind of like
Scientology right and their orgs they
had so many of these little orgs and
[__] you never know what these
individual leaders are doing they didn't
have a lot of oversight
yeah and if you have power over people
who are more vulnerable than you and you
don't have a lot of oversight then
that's gonna lead to problems most
people are probably going to be fine or
they're going to just like do whatever
but it's like that's always going to
attract a certain kind of people and
honestly any job that
um you know where you have to like deal
with a lot of kids like you know
Catholic priests or you know Boy Scout
leaders [__] like that you're always
going to get a certain percentage of
dudes of pedos that are going to come in
there like specifically for that reason
so you know
you can't like [__] on everybody in the
profession because of that because it's
it's generally just a small profession
percentage but
it is gonna happen any kind of job that
um you know necessitates you
interacting with a lot of kids all the
time or oracle's talking to me about
Adam he's the 80s yeah what does it say
what does it say if you want to flash
back to your teen years try Adam eats
the 80s yeah I had that that was a white
album with black with a black image of
of Adam Ant on it it had beat my guest
on it and a whole bunch of
yeah I had that album I think I had that
I had that I don't think that's an album
I think that's a YouTube
oh it's a channel okay I had an album
and I had a Man album either that or a
series I can't remember right then I
don't I don't know it then I had an
album that was an Adam album that was I
think it was I thought it was named that
I mean it could be but I can't really
remember it was like yeah Adam yeah
Oracle said Adam eats the 80s is a TV
show oh he eats foods that were big in
the 1980s oh okay all right I thought
there was an adamant B-side album that's
what it was called
B-side something or other
that's how I thought you're talking
about
yeah Oracle said it's on Hulu now oh I
might have to watch that because I love
all that I love
um like the weird history Food Channel
and I especially like when they talk
about like all the 80s [__]
some of the food back then I mean the
80s food is weird but it's not as weird
as the 70s food
this food was [__] goopy
in the United States it was all white
gravy on [__] that's true starchy heavy
stodgy [__]
always had some kind of damp country
gravy on it
like [__] and it's weird because when
I was growing like I'm not a huge fan of
putting tons of gravy or sauce or
something like I like to taste the
actual food not like all the stuff that
you're putting like I'm not you know
don't get me wrong I like like a little
bit of sauce or like a little bit of
gravy but it's like sometimes like the
[__] they would have like if you go to
like [__] even nowadays if you go to
Cracker Barrel or someplace like that
like they'll just drown [__] yeah in
great that's like I can't eat that and I
can't eat that sorry I'm not being a
snot I just can't everything yeah I just
can't eat that everything looked like
[__]
clam chowder there's some kind of white
and nothing wrong and look I love clams
yeah everything looked like a white
gravy on something it's like wait is
there even any food under here or is
this just a soup it's a potato with
cheese on it and bacon bits with hash
browns on top of that with a [__]
some cheese on top of the hash browns
and then you pour [__] country gravy
on it
and put biscuits next to it that's
that's how [__] that's up to 80s food
10 000 calories a million calories
God it's like that's what I mean it's
like people eating like that now what
are they [__] yeah look like crap
when they were [__] 50 years old yeah
their whole [__] life it's just like
I was saying before me and me and Soph
were talking about it says yeah the
people that are 70 now they [__] what
they grew up eating was some [__]
[__]
at least in this country in this country
what they grew up eating some [__]
crazy crap you'd never see anymore see
anything
seen you that anymore
I mean you do but it's like at least
most people nowadays are just kind of
like that's bad food they know that
that's bad for you it's like well maybe
I'll eat that once a year yeah like on a
special tastes good but it's bad for you
right so it's like you don't really get
and you'd only be able to get that like
Waffle House or Denny's and I'm not sure
Cracker Barrel or Cracker Barrel yeah
and to be honest even restaurants like
this they have cleaned up their ass have
kind of like gone in more healthy just
because that's the way the market is
going like you can't really get away
with yeah these big stodgy 10 000
calories yeah plates anymore because a
lot of people just won't eat those no
and the people that grew up on those are
dead now that's well yeah partially
because they've been they were eating
that their whole way yeah yeah and like
I said I'm not saying that shit's not
delicious because it is yeah but it's
just like you can't
you can't eat like that I for sure can't
eat like that especially not anymore I
can maybe eat like that when I was
younger yeah but even then it was just
kind of like man it would make me feel
really ill yeah they had that and then
when I was up in Michigan
all your manpa Italian restaurants all
had the same [__] Cisco backing Cisco
food delivery and it was all the [__]
same lasagna the same Pizza the same
[__] sauce everything was exactly
this [__] thing
and it was like a million calories
remember that I would just be hard you
probably didn't have those for out here
well no they did yeah all the Italian
restaurants were the same they were like
Italian fast food it was just yeah
yeah lots and lots of mostaccioli
well that's what I'm and honestly like
if you watch some of those old like
Gordon Ramsay like not Hell's Kitchen
but um kitchen nightmare kitchen
nightmare like he went to a lot of those
kind of like shitty old-fashioned like
little Italian restaurants yeah where
they had those massive menus and like
they had these huge plates of [__]
and nothing Italian about them nothing
no not really not really this is it was
the America it was a mutated American
version of Italian food although I find
like I said I find food history
fascinating
and as I especially find the history of
various immigrants to the United States
like the way that their food
you know changed like when they came
here and started kind of trying to make
it more marketable to American palettes
and I find that really interesting too
and if you like I said if you look into
anything like
Italian restaurants or even like Chef
Boyardee who is a real guy by the way
um like the way that that came about is
like really really interesting to me but
Italian restaurants
you know they're they're better now I
guess than they used to be but I think
for a Time particularly in the 80s you
had this thing where
more was better yeah like they you'd go
in they'd have this menu it was like a
[__] novel yeah and then you go in
and they give these massive massive
places just like all this stuff would
just like just covered in like sauce and
cheese and it's just like yeah thousands
and thousands of calories I'm sure it
was pasta
any old marinara sauce that they put on
there even thinking about that gives me
heartburn now it is
you know what I mean yeah it's just kind
of like I can't
I couldn't really even eat that much
when I was younger and I was much
heavier but especially nowadays like the
older I get like the the less I can eat
in one sitting without feeling like
really really ill even when we go to the
um
even when we go to the Chinese buffet to
the Chinese buffet
I've noticed that like every successive
time we go because we've gone like for
the last few weekends it's like and I
find myself like just being able to eat
less and less yeah like as the time goes
on
like it's good though I think last time
I think I got one plate of just you
wanna go tomorrow sure all right
I think you know I'm sure yeah yeah I
mean honestly and all I eat there like I
said I don't eat any carbs yeah no just
meat just protein I just eat and
vegetables yeah Protein that's all he is
protein and vegetables
if you're a bodybuilder or you're into
health if you find a good
Chinese buffet you can get a clean meal
in there
eat the boiled shrimp just don't eat any
noodles or raisins look I love noodles
okay but it's like just don't eat any of
that right but the uh they got
broccoli and fresh vegetables you should
get a whole salad bar salad bar yeah
they got like yeah they got like really
nice they had like a cucumber tomato
kind of thing going on like I had some
of that they got like all kind of cold
salads they got I was like chicken
boiled eggs chicken thigh yeah on a damn
stick yeah you know what I mean so you
can go in there and eat just essentially
zero carbs and you can still like fill
up yeah fill up on [__] protein
but that's what I do I go and get one
plate which which is usually like
boy like broiled fish
um
some pepper steak with that which has
you know green peppers and onions then
I'll get like a little bit of chicken
and a bunch of broccoli a bunch of
mushrooms yeah and I'll have like a
plate of that and then I'll have a plate
of like shrimp and a couple of uh uh
scallops yeah and then or mussels rather
yeah that's just up the road here and
then then we after we get done with that
we uh go to the [__] books a million
and uh they have the [__] coffee
place in there Joe mugs Joe mugs and the
girls know us there they'll make us my
[__] cold brew
cold brew [__] ice cream yeah they it
wasn't even the special last month and
and they made us a cinnamon toast one
yeah because we said well that was your
best one and she said well I can make
you one if you want it I was like yeah
okay
well they make a different flavor
like the Barista there she makes
um different flavors like every time we
go
so
we had Cinnamon Toast Crunch that was
the best one and then she did like a
peanut butter cup one that was also good
and then last then one time we were
there we did she did a raspberry danish
which was good but I'm not super into
raspberry but it made them good it makes
them good is that they're not sweet
they're yeah they're still real they're
they're still kind of bitter they're
very coffee forward which I'm into
because like I like the Starbucks
drinks but the Starbucks drinks are very
sweet like they're essentially like a
milkshake that has that maybe had like a
cop like a whiff of coffee flavor wafted
over it for a second but it's like the
ones that she makes you can still tell
that it's the flavor that she makes but
it's still very very coffee forward
which you know I like what coffee tastes
like
so I kind of want it to still taste like
coffee and not like a milkshake you know
we've been streaming for over two hours
I know you okay
I can see it it's right there
I can see it I got glasses on
but yeah so
um yeah so the girl that works there
she's always there like on Saturdays and
she's really cool so she'll always make
us something I mean we told her we're
like we like all of the stuff that she
makes but the cinnamon toast one was the
best one
because man
can't beat [__] cinnamon and coffee I
love that [__] together
um let's see
oh yeah
Magdalene laundries
that's kind of another show that
we should probably do because that was a
whole [__] up situation
Victor says okay I'm back I had to leave
as soon as I got here yo what happened
I wondered where you went
we're still here just getting drunker
and drunker we're not going anyplace so
you know what I mean
we're not going anyplace today so we're
just sitting here getting drunk like we
usually do
Zach says the Starbucks pumpkin spice is
basic but good and as they say a million
white girls can't be wrong honestly yeah
and I know that it's kind of like a
cliche that it's just like oh it's it's
like the quintessential Karen drink but
I'm just gonna say I like the I like the
pumpkin spice latte okay I like pumpkin
spice stuff I'm not gonna go out of my
way to get it but
and the thing about it is that when it
comes out it always reminds me it's like
ooh fall is coming and it's like
Halloween is coming we were in Dollar
General yesterday I was going by into
like some lunch [__] and some cat food
stuff
and they got some of their Halloween
candy out already and I was like so
excited
it's like I know it's only July but
Halloween [__] is already starting to
turn up in the stores so
you know what I mean and that's always
makes me happy because it's like the
quicker that fall comes the better
because I hate [__] summer it's my
least favorite
it's my least favorite season we don't
have that much longer left and spring is
my second least favorite what do we got
I hate I hate spring another what two
three months Maybe well no it's gonna be
hot all year but I'm just saying that
it's like maybe it cools down maybe in
october-ish sometimes the night time
starts cooling down or the mornings are
cooler yeah so a couple months yeah yeah
so it's like so July's almost over yeah
which is exciting
so a couple months it'll start cooling
down I'm just and it's kind of sad I
don't like to like wish my life away but
it's like every time summer comes in
Florida I'm just like waiting for I'm
just like
waiting for summer to be over
I hate summer I hate it
I've always hated it yeah John Gore said
Walgreens got the Halloween candy
already yeah Dollar General did too they
don't they don't have a ton of it but
they do have like some because I was
like oh look like the Halloween candy
that always me though I love Halloween
so that makes pictures back yeah I saw
that yeah
yeah Victor said I can't wait for these
cold fronts to start dropping yeah me
too I mean it's gonna be a while here in
Florida because it's not even August yet
and
July and August are the hottest months
and then
you have September and September is
usually the worst month for like
hurricane type [__]
so I mean if a bad hurricane is gonna
hit it's usually gonna be in September
so we gotta live through that
hurricane season is technically not over
until November
30th November 1st
November I don't remember if it's the
beginning of November the end of
November but
September is actually even though it's
not the hottest month it's actually like
the worst month for hurricanes because
so much heat builds up
in the ocean like over the hot months
that by the time September Comes Around
it's like the Hurricanes get worse and
worse
hopefully we'll Dodge it this year but
still early days
okay um
what do you guys want us to talk about
Zack says I love fall most but also
because it's one of the only times a
year in hit in Indy where it looks
pretty
yeah I mean fall and winter growing up
in Florida I'm just always been like and
I'm always really jealous of people that
grew up in places where there's actual
Seasons like where the leaves changed
and where there was like snow and stuff
like that because we don't have that
like our leaves don't really change
everything's just green all the time
sometimes the grass will die but usually
the grass dies from like it being too
hot
rather than it being fall
you know
this is like sometimes the sun will just
like bake the grass and kill it rather
than it's because it's too cold you know
what I mean
yeah so yeah I was never really
emotionally connected to it
seasons
well I often had all that and I just it
I didn't really care well like I said
I'm only like that because it's just
kind of like you grew up in Florida it's
just like the same like all the time
yeah and it gets really old no it's just
hot
and then less hot and it'll get a little
bit cold and then it'll go back to hot
unless that's what I mean yeah in
Monsoon Seasons it's it's actually the
the weather is very similar here
well no I wouldn't say Korea
Korea gets a lot because Korea gets
super cold and colder it never gets
super cold here I mean every now and
then it'll freeze but it's like one
night yeah like out of the year yeah
like they're like oh my God one night
it's gonna go down to like 29 degrees
everybody cover up your [__] plane
but I don't miss it I wasn't I'm not
really turned on by snow I I don't
really care no I like cold weather yeah
I like cold weather I like fall weather
I like cool weather I don't like you
don't live in it have you lived in it no
because I'm like you know when I get
sick well no when I actually went to
like the UK for a while and it was like
really cold over there and rain and
stuff like that I was really into that
doesn't get as cold there I think as it
does in places like Michigan I don't
well no but you know it was like pretty
cold I mean you get sick of anything
that you experience all the time right
so because I grew up in Florida I was
born here like you get really sick of
hot weather it gets like really boring I
like the South you can ride all year
round
motorcycles all year round it doesn't
matter
even in the cold weather you can ride
it's not that cold
yeah it it's never gotten below
I think the coldest I've ever
experienced here was probably like
mid-20s yeah which is cold but it's not
that cool you're like you're not gonna
die or anything you know what I mean
yeah so we're gonna sit around just talk
about the weather what you guys want to
talk about
we can talk about anything don't get all
judgy right they're talking about the
weather
okay um why are you so cranky
you've been so cranky this whole show
John Gore said up in New England spring
is always welcome yeah then Ben said
don't move to Australia then we're
looking at a very hot summer in a few
months yeah you guys have summer at the
opposite time I always forget that
yeah we're having summer now and it's
not like not super fun also because it
kind of sucks because where I work
there's no
break room yeah Victor we could always
talk about grits we're talking about
grits Tammy said let's talk about Tom
getting pegged yeah okay yeah let's talk
about that let's talk about that I don't
talk about that oh we'll see okay so you
don't want to talk about the weather but
we can't talk about you getting packed
up we got [__] we got people online
[Laughter]
just because you don't want to talk
about it it doesn't mean other people
don't mean that's like Rock Bottom to
talk about the weather
that's a rock bottom it's actually can
we talk about why breakfast food is the
best food breakfast food is the best
food because you associate it with
[__] coming out of the club at night
drunk off your ass and the shit's
[__] greasy and succulent
it's eggs
sausage eggs are always good they're on
potatoes yeah
so there's just something about
breakfast Western American and English
breakfast food yeah because I was gonna
say the English the English kind of have
the same thing it's very similar very
similar they do it a little bit
differently but and then the South our
version of breakfast is different than
the North's version of breakfast we got
different stuff on it
but it's still breakfast
and everybody would be satisfied by
everybody else's breakfast basically
the Chinese don't have breakfast all
right even Brazil when I lived there
they don't have breakfast the way we
have it
they have Cafe de Maya which means like
morning coffee which is coffee
maybe a little bit of orange juice bread
like french bread type stuff with butter
and maybe like some melon
yeah I find I feel like like they do
that in like France yeah it's like that
all right which is probably healthier
but but we have real breakfast which is
based on an English breakfast
our our breakfast is based on English
breakfast
like I said it is very yeah yeah that
was that was the basis and it mutated
from there
our breakfast is so good that even the
Mexicans like our breakfast
yeah although the thing about it is if
if you ate that for breakfast every day
you would give that you would die yeah
you would weigh 500 pounds and you would
die of like heart failure there are by
the time you were 30. there are American
Mexican breakfast Fusion action happens
too
certain areas
can I tell you that one of my favorite
things about staying in a hotel is that
[__] breakfast buffet yeah well
because the thing about it is that
because I get up so early to go to work
and [__] like that it's like I don't
ever I never eat breakfast I get up I
don't eat anything
um I take like some iced coffee like
some black coffee with me to work like I
drink on the way there
but I don't eat anything until like one
o'clock in the afternoon Tammy's talking
about me getting pegged with with grits
yeah damn Tammy you you
you're imaginative see see how it is see
I got a fancy account already set up I
don't have any video on it yet though
you need to make some [__] for that I
keep waiting yeah and I'm gonna get
these girls to [__] you keep telling
it's like that's the thing you keep
telling me it's like you need to shoot
this that and the other thing but you
haven't shot a single [__] thing yeah
okay maybe you shoot something this
weekend okay all right you're gonna have
to [__] beat the camera camera okay
all right let me shoot something I'll
put that up on my fans League I keep
waiting for you to do it but you never
do it we got to get several things on
the fansley yeah and uh if you guys know
what fansley is fans he's kind of like
only fans but it's like ghetto only fans
but you but we get paid more
uh on fansley only fans takes a lot
takes a lot from you
I got my [__] only I got my fans lit
account approved and Jenny still hasn't
gotten hers approved for some reason
that's taking forever they gotta be
[__] you over
they must have approved you
or something's wrong have you checked it
lately
no I checked it a few days ago but it's
probably approved by now that way we can
tag each other yeah
that's another place we can put videos
yeah but like I said I gotta set up many
vids this week and see how much of a
pain in the ass that is like I
understand like that you have to jump
through a bunch of Hoops because they
want to make sure look everybody's
consenting and if he's underage and blah
blah like I get that but you know it is
kind of a pain in the ass when you're
[__] 50 years old and yeah they're
asking you for all these [__] proofs
to this now there's like look I'm old
just let me [__] put the [__] up it's
fine
but yeah so
I don't know man those like I feel like
I always
the idea of like having like a big huge
breakfast like a Denny's or something
like that is always like super cool but
it's like I never
like I said when I'm going to work I
never I don't have time or inclination I
just have coffee and that's it
but even on the weekends it's like
usually by the time we get up and get
dressed and do that kind of [__] it's
like lunch time so and then we usually
just go to the buffet and
eat shrimp so
but every now and then I would like to
go out and get some there's actually
like a breakfast place
right down the street like right next to
the Publix what the [__] is that place
called Sunshine something that's gone
now something like that is it I think
it's gone something went out of business
over there I think I think that was no
it wasn't now
I think that's still there there was
something else next to it that went out
of business there's still like there's
an ice cream and coffee place there I
think that's still there but like yeah
it's I think it's called Sunrise cafe or
something they're only open they do
lunch too but I think they're only up
until two in the afternoon
so you know what I mean yeah I think
it's so I think it's anyway since she's
covering all the [__] time yeah I
think it's hilarious how everybody wants
to see you get pegged
[__] you [__] we brought we brought up
that idea and everybody's like yeah that
should happen
it's a female fantasy that's been
happening throughout [__] the entire
space time continuum they all want to
see that but see that's the thing
but see that's the thing like dudes
expect women to cater to their fantasies
but they won't reciprocate they won't
reciprocate we say hey we want to we
want to stand the other like no I'm not
doing that but you have to do all this
stuff though like for me but I but you
know what I mean so yeah I'm just saying
that's how that goes women don't buy
enough they don't pay enough
they don't buy porn
what am I gonna do I'm gonna [__] put
with the dragon dildo on the end stick
that on the wall I'm gonna back up to
that [__] and just like [__] just
yeah why not rough ride that
[__] just make it let's make it
all kinds of noise
that would be funny though
I don't know I don't know [__] are
crazy I don't know how boner do you
think that would be but it would be very
important
[__] and make that video and [__] up my
reputation and everything and only
[__] three girls would buy it
well it's like what is this dudes would
buy it
share it [__] look at look at look at
Ross
[Laughter]
I mean do you really have that much of a
I get a rep to protect do you really
have that much of a rep to protect them
oh yeah you do hell yeah you think
[__] right
Victor says I want to see Tom get pegged
by a dude yeah Victor we know you do
I would like to see that too but Victor
wants to come down here and do this I
know for sure yeah
unless I unless I figure out how to do
like um 3D animation to a good enough
standard which I may just do you [__]
[__] all you horse I'll do a deep fake
I saw some [__] deep fake porn I was
quite impressed
it was uh a deep fake of [__] uh Rey
Skywalker from [__] Star Wars she was
uh hit a gang bang somebody yeah see the
defects are real yeah I was like God
damn what's that girl what's that
Exorcist name
um oh [__] uh [__] Australian accent
wait I knew it yeah
which I don't understand Daisy Ridley
Daisy Ridley yeah
Daisy Ridley as [__] um
as [__] Ray Skywalker in a gag bag
there's a deep fake
I don't yeah I can I I laughed at it but
I mean Daisy Ridley's she's she's a cute
chick but there's just nothing sexual
about that character at all it's one of
the most unsexiest characters in all the
[__] Star Wars she was probably I was
surprised to say
some a lot of girls like even you told
me the [__] Luke Skywalker was not
sexy the Han was sexy but not Luke and
Ray was even less sexy than [__] well
because Luke seemed too much like a a
kid yeah he seemed like a kid well and I
think the same thing was true of Rey she
seemed very young and I don't think she
was really supposed to be like she
wasn't portrayed as being those movies
sexy in any way those movies were
[__] Abominations but like I said I
think Han Solo was sexy because he was
older he was funny and he was funny and
he kind of had more of like a
personality type of thing and he was
kind of more of like
I don't know if I want to say like like
he was kind of like more hard to get I
guess he was the bad guy kind of and
kind of yeah he wasn't like a bad dude
like he was a good dude but he was just
kind of like a little bit like morally
yeah they changed Han a bit okay
I remember in 1977 I [__] saw that
[__] [__] man's Chinese Theater done
[__] L.A I was a kid my dad took us
to me and [__] I love that movie man
we saw that thing like [__] four
times in a row it's like in like every
few days we go back and see it again my
Dad loved it too
they changed solo
solo shot first he shot Greedo and
killed him they let you let you know
right from the very beginning the
[__] Pond was dangerous
that's what I mean there was probably
like a reason that he did it was
gangsters they were gangsters that's
what I mean everybody back then was just
kind of like well he probably had that
guy they were all Outlaws when you're
when you when when it's two Outlaws it
doesn't matter it's I mean it's it's in
the world of or of the underworld you
know what I mean but that's what made
Han so cool is that he was dangerous
and and that's what made that character
so good
even though it was
not fully explained and he was actually
if you go back and you watch the movies
that's very G-rated the way he was with
[__] uh Princess Leia and everything
I thought it was very cute
you know but uh come on you know you
love me and all that kind of stuff you
know and him [__] trying to
work his charms on this [__] princess
some of that [__] were like wait a
minute hold on he forced himself on her
yeah that's the way it was back then
[__] but the thing is is that
ha knew
he could read body language man
he knew [__] Princess Leia was had
the hots for him she was just holding it
back
you know he was he was a [__]
scoundrel he he knew
he knew she was into him and she was
but like I said I think the reason why
that character weren't and I think
here's what a lot of people like Miss
perceive it's just like oh like all
these you know women they like bad boys
and stuff like that they don't like bad
boys like villains they don't like evil
people yeah they like dudes that are
deep down good dudes yeah but
are willing to do some like morally
questionable [__] if necessary to get it
done pray so I kind of because Han Solo
wasn't a bad guy no he wasn't evil he
wasn't sociopathic he had an honor code
yeah
he just did like he was honest yeah he
was honest he just did he did some
questionable [__] but it wasn't anything
like he wasn't he was a drug Smuggler
right he was a drug Smuggler but he was
an organized crime there's different
kinds of guys that they're looking for
and
when it comes to things like smuggling
and shipping and
[__] certain kind of transactions you
have to be a criminal but you have to be
an honest criminal you're a chain of
command has to be able to trust you
right that you're saying that that the
numbers are correct and you're actually
you're reliable you know it's not so
he's like so it's kind of like the
perfect thing because he's kind of like
he's willing to do stuff outside the law
if he needs to but he's still like a
good honest dude like he wouldn't
do anything to [__] you over like I said
he's not like a sociopath or anything
like that he still has a code of honor
of his own
yeah
but um and then John Gore said he wanted
Han wanted to believe in something
besides himself and his own Lookout yeah
he also asked you guys ever cover Once
Upon a Time in Hollywood I only just saw
it very worthwhile that was a great yeah
I own it we saw it we saw it twice in
the theater yeah um I think we did a
review of it did we know like after we
saw it in the theater I think we did a
review and then I bought it yeah I
[__] love it I think I bought it for
you if you think you wanted to ask me
about it I've seen it many times if you
want to ask me anything about it I can
answer about that uh what he was talking
about with uh what was that what did he
say about it oh yeah Han wanted
something outside of himself Paul wanted
to uh like you're you're correct
Han wanted to learn how to not be
selfish yeah okay
and that was his whole character Arc
right
he was a selfish dude who was
self-reliant he was a good guy
but he
wanted
to have friends
and to have a higher purpose
and to be altruistic and that's he
became altruistic yeah the end of a new
hope he didn't have to go back
and go to the Death Star and be in yeah
he could have just left yeah he could
have just left but he went back to the
Death Star and when he got there he saw
that Luke was in trouble and he [__]
saved Luke so Luke could make the
[__] shot and if Luke hadn't made
that shot the Death Star wouldn't have
been destroyed right so in a way
Han's support
made Luke and the end of the Death Star
possible yeah
without without without Han that
wouldn't have happened probably
because yeah Luke was strong with the
dark side but he wasn't
fully trained and he wasn't
[__] a God or infallible he could
have missed that shot he could have been
shot before he took the shot
but Han was there and saved him yeah
well that was kind of like like I said
that was the whole point of his
character Arc yeah the start the
original Star Wars was
Luke's hero's journey but Han had his
own Peril and you know Leia had her own
parallel thing too yeah but Han had his
own parallel thing where he was learning
to be like you said less self-centered
yeah like he was a good guy before he
wasn't a villain or anything like that
but he just had never had any cause to
rise above himself and like sack like
sacrifice himself like for other people
that he cared about and the fact that he
was given that opportunity and he
actually Rose to the occasion that was
kind of his big character moment
groundbreaking story okay it would have
never happened today
they would never write a story like that
now because if you actually read in
between the lines
how would a is a drug Smuggler he's a
drug Smuggler that's what haunt was
okay
in a movie today he'd have been [__]
just treated been treated like [__] he
was a drug Smuggler he Ard that'd be the
equivalent of like [__] the dude
working for the Mexican cartels bringing
in bringing in [__] uh fentanyl or
something that's basically what he was
doing
but he was more than that that's just
what he was doing that's not what kind
of guy he was he was just trying to
eventually we all grew out of that and
um
so the moral of the story was is that
people can be redeemed yeah yeah that's
what it meant which is a good message
yeah
sure I'm cynical and [__] like that but
most people are okay people
like if given the opportunity
most of them would probably be all right
you know what I mean very few people are
just like straight up evil
so I like that I like that they made him
like you said a morally gray character
like where he was kind of operating
outside of the law
he wasn't really doing anything to hurt
anybody directly
but still him shooting Greedo would have
been second degree murder
yeah that's true yeah but like I said
any any anything but like nobody I mean
nobody blamed him at the time because
it's like well it was probably him or
exactly you know it's like he was going
to get shot otherwise but the thing is
is it goes to show you in that morality
tale that legality is not morality
all right if you yeah had that been
in a civilized place
even in here in the south
which some people might say is not that
civilized but it's like New Orleans or
something no he would have gotten a
second degree of murder for that
all right
but in reality what you're dealing with
you're dealing with two gangsters
they're they're not in society they're
outside of society
so the kind of fair game for each other
the law wouldn't see it that way but
that's how they saw it yeah
and I agree more with that you know it
was a situation well and I have to say
too that in the original movie it
probably softened the blow somewhat that
Greedo was not a human
so it's probably like easier for
audiences at the time to like stomach it
was like well he was an alien so is that
right
Han killed a lot of Stormtroopers and
those were humans and that's true and
they worked for the government but they
were faceless they were infant yeah but
then so it's like you could you could
rub out a bunch of Stormtroopers well
and that's and in a way well I know but
it's like I kind of like that the um the
newer ones introduced the idea of like
uh you know a stormtrooper guy that like
escaped like got out of there so it's
like it humanized the Stormtroopers so
it almost also kind of made you like go
back to the earlier ones and be like man
they like rubbed out all this storm and
some of those dudes might have been like
look I'm just here like punching a clock
man it's like I don't really believe any
of this [__] and it's like and
they're just getting shot left and right
people fail to to realize that at the
time
of the New Hope all right
the Empire is the legitimate government
they're the legitimate government
they're wreck they're they're recognized
legitimate government of the Galaxy all
right and the Stormtroopers would be
like the equivalent of the US Army and
the Navy combined
so really Luke and Han and all those
guys [__] in the Death Star [__]
breaking the princess out of prison and
[__] they're terrorists
if you were to do that to the United
States right now they would just call
you a terrorists but that's really what
it was you know that that's what they're
done that's what they were the Rebel
Alliance was a terrorist group basically
well that's why I kind of liked Rogue
one because it kind of showed you that
that's what it was leaned into that but
they were still like the good guys you
know yeah
yeah Ben says when we were kids we
thought the Stormtroopers were robots
yeah so do we when we were little and
then later you're like oh wait that was
I didn't even realize that until the
part in A New Hope where Luke and Han
like steal the Stormtroopers uniforms
and I was just kind of like oh [__]
that's just like armor those are people
under there yeah like I thought they
were robots too
um Ben says when you were talking about
uh being a drug dealer being like the
hero or whatever yeah Ben says I saw a
movie like that recently there was a
single mom smuggling meth in a truck
across the border it was called
something like Midnight Express
I've never seen that one yeah
and I kind of feel like there's a lot of
store I don't know there's a lot of
stories nowadays about like sympathetic
drug dealers
well [__] they made a whole series about
a sympathetic Serial Killer Dexter so
you know in a lot of ways I kind of feel
like it's more likely that they would
make that [__] nowadays because
everybody's into like the anti-hero they
make a lot of stuff about anti-heroes
nowadays so everybody likes like
somebody that's kind of like
not necessarily a good person as being
the main character
no Greedo wasn't considered a law
enforcement officer Greta was basically
a uh a bounty hunter
remember he was trying to collect a
bounty didn't he work for a job with a
hot dog yeah yeah he was trying to
collect the Bounty of the Jabba wanted
he did work for the for the huts
the Huts yeah that's what they call them
the Huts the Hutt family well it wasn't
a family it was a race
that's where [__] a race of gangsters
yeah Jabba the Hutt Bubba the Hut yeah
yeah
but uh they were in weren't they wasn't
it called the outer rim
I think that's what they said yeah I
think it might have been called the
outer rim the place where Tatooine was
was outside of the Republic
so it was the it was the Badlands
it was run by the huts
and they had slavery there even all
right and it was uh not a a good place
evidently the the empire was there but
it wasn't fully part of the empire
so Greedo yeah it would have been kind
of like a law enforcement officer
because he worked for the huts and the
Huts ran the place
but you technically is alone yeah but
not in the in the sense that you might
be thinking of it well I don't think
they had a legitimate government right
yeah Victor says Pizza The Hut yeah well
that yeah that was uh yeah
Spaceballs baseball
I'm sorry I love Spaceballs
have you seen that in a while have you
seen that right I could I couldn't stand
that one for some really I didn't Yeah
by that I thought I really like space I
thought that was towards that when I saw
that movie I thought Mel Brooks had
[__] like reached the end the end of
his [__] directorial [__] lifespan
I just thought the humor was bad
I like baseballs I didn't love Robin
Hood Men in Tights yeah although that I
I haven't seen that in a long time so I
should probably go back and re-watch it
although I went back and watched history
of the world and it wasn't funny either
I thought it was funny when I was a kid
but he's he's not that funny
that humor didn't age that well
although high anxiety might be good
I haven't seen that in a while either I
kind of want to re-watch some of that I
mean Blazing Saddles is still yeah it is
that's funny that's very still like
really funny Young Frankenstein is
something yeah Young Frankenstein is
still [__] hilarious yeah we just
watched that a few months ago and that's
still [__] funny
um John Gore said I love the job in the
hot Lair as a kid with all this monsters
yeah we had the job of the hot um
playset yeah my brother passed a lot of
stuff John's asking about when Pitt's
stunman he must have been asking me a
question
remember he was about about uh Once Upon
a Time in Hollywood yeah what's he
saying when Pitch stunt man sing no to
the
hitchhiker's proposition under the
pretense of one
to be within statutory law I was just
seeing
to keep up his strength for the rescue
mission at the ranch I don't know
exactly remember like in Once Upon a
Time in Hollywood he picks up that
teenage girl yeah the girl was from the
family yeah and she's like all trying to
like yeah even though and he's like kept
asking her how old she was yeah she went
to what about it
I don't know I'm just saying that's what
he's referring to yeah but I don't know
what he's talking about I'm just saying
that's what he's talking about you have
to uh ask it a little more explicitly
because I can't get it something about
his power
for the final what rescue
do you see it
I don't know it's like it scrolled way
up here
oh [__] what happened
something popped up in like [__]
no I can't find it
oh and Pit Stop man saying to The
Hitchhiker's proposition the pretense of
waiting to be wanting to be the
statutory laws seem to keep up the
strength for his rescue mission of the
ranch okay so I get what he's saying I
don't care so he's saying that
um Brad Pitt picking up The Hitchhiker
he was a teenager and then they had this
whole thing where she was trying like
trying to jump on that dick and he's
just like look how old are you and blah
blah but it's like the fact that he
didn't succumb to that like helped him
like maintain his strength for the later
battle that he had like at the ranch
where he had to like confront because
remember he punched out that dude
she's saying [__] the girl would have
made him weak I don't understand
never mind Tom yeah
never mind now you can screw all kinds
of girls you don't get weaker you can
you can you can still fight
Victor says Gremlins 3 is supposed to
come out at the end of the year y'all
should review the first two I think we
did the first one like as a Christmas
review right
yeah we did the first crap Gremlins
either last Christmas or the Christmas
before I don't remember if we done
gremlis 2. I don't like Gremlins 2 as
much because it's more of like an overt
comedy whereas I feel like the first one
is
not a horror movie necessarily but it's
much more of a black comedy I don't know
the second one is much funnier it's like
more satirical which
it's still good but it's like it's not
it's too much in the comedy end of
things he answered
uh seem to make psychological sense for
Pitt to not blow his load before going
about his Good Deed yeah yeah I see what
you're saying like he's saying just like
from a movie standpoint
that was kind of like important that he
was able to be like yeah no I'm not
going down that route I got this other
[__] I gotta do like later on it doesn't
have anything to do with like really oh
I can [__] all these chicks and still
fight like you know what I mean that
doesn't have anything to do with
anything he's talking about like in a
narrative sense that's what he was
talking about I just thought they were
just trying to let you know that he was
a good guy
well that too right well yeah they're
just gonna he's not gonna take advantage
of even if something is like a you know
just apparently like given to him on a
platter yeah like he's just gonna be
like nah yeah which like I said that
does it it demonstrates that he's like a
decent yeah dude because like my
interpreter right like a lot of a lot of
dudes would just be like okay
you know what I mean and not like not
worry about it I would say a lot of
dudes say about half of them
well that's a lot yeah that's a lot I
don't know man
I don't know if half is a lot it is a
lot because a lot of dudes are shitty
all right exactly more than half well
that's what I mean I think even a lot of
well yeah you got no argument for me I
think a lot of you think even even a lot
of the shitty guys that go like nah
yeah well and I think a lot of the
shitty dudes would go nah not because
they didn't want to but because they
were afraid they would get in trouble
well yeah of course you're gonna want to
you're gonna watch it yeah it's just
it's just that's just biology you can go
but she wants to [__] man she's cute
I probably shouldn't do this though
you're just gonna do that you know
that's how it is
um
they were just the way my interpretation
was is that they wanted you to know that
the Brad Pitt's character stunt man
character that he was a good guy yeah
all right that he stood from he had
principles
and he also wanted to know that they
wanted you to know that he wasn't
desperate
yeah he was a good looking guy in
Hollywood
he had all kinds of women you know he
didn't need to take advantage of some
homeless semi-homeless hippie chick from
Charles Manson's cult you know what I
mean that wouldn't his style he had
higher standards than that
even though she was cute but they also
wanted you to know that she had hair
underneath her arms
okay
[Laughter]
I shaved my underarms man stinky ass
[__]
it does help like with that yeah yeah
I mean I'm not saying like something but
yeah it is much easier to like not have
that yeah Tammy said anyone seen
Oppenheimer yet we were you know what we
were gonna go see it last weekend
but one I discovered that it was three
hours long and two I ended up we were
gonna get we had planned to go see it on
last Saturday and then I got like a
whole bunch of like freelance work and I
was just kind of like man I really can't
justify like sitting in a movie theater
for three hours when I could be like
working on all of this stuff even though
I really wanted to see it so we ended up
like not seeing it
I still really want to see it though
so we'll we'll get around to it but like
I said I just didn't have time last
weekend we're sucked
Ben said uh Brad Pitt's character was
the knight in shining armor of the fairy
tale yeah exactly
Tammy said yeah but she was a hippie in
the 70s yeah I kind of feel like that
was that was a whole thing that was the
whole thing and it wasn't just hippies
because I kind of feel like a lot of
people
the 70s were just kind of like all about
being natural man so everybody had
[__]
not everybody but a lot of people had
like underarm hair and Bush and
everything like that like people weren't
like really worried now everybody's just
like man shave all that [__] off but you
know back then it wasn't like that they
weren't grossed out by it
I don't know I'm not I don't feel one
way or the other about it I'm just kind
of like look it's other people's bodies
they can do whatever the [__] they want
with it
I'm not
hair doesn't gross me out one way or the
other
so
um
I personally don't don't want it there
so I just shave everything off but
if other people want it that's fine it
doesn't bother me it really it doesn't
gross me out or anything so
I don't know I'm just I'm not bothered
although one thing I do want to say
about
Once Upon a Time in Hollywood
that I'm coming in from the restroom
coming in here
Once Upon a Time the Hollywood did call
a lot of [__] that was pretty cool
and one of the things that that movie
addressed and [__] Quinn
me and Quinn go way back we went to the
same Elementary School man
we went to we went to uh [__]
Dominguez elementary school he was a
couple years older than me but I
remember him
uh I remember that dude
he ended up working at the [__]
video store next to the Mexican
restaurant my dad used to take me to
when I was a kid it was called el
ranchitos yeah yeah I remember that
place
and next to that [__] Mexican
restaurant
and that video store that Clinton
Tarantino worked was the library where
I would see the World War II books
yeah yeah it was right there
Clinton talked about
Bruce Lee
and they had the [__] um scene where
the Brad Pitt's character
the uh
stunt man
[__] threw Bruce Lee into the [__]
car door if I get [__] [__] up
evidently something like that did happen
that that character is based on a real
stunt man and evidently that did happen
people forget that Bruce Lee was not a
professional fighter Bruce Lee came from
Hong Kong theater type stuff he did do
a few Martial Arts events
but his management told him to look man
you can't do that you're gonna get hurt
and you're gonna miss your shooting
schedule because I think he was doing
[__] Green Hornet at that time yeah
he made him want him getting hurt
um
I've done a lot of research on Bruce not
a lot but yeah I guess I've done a lot
but they got other dudes that are just
total freaks that are [__] know
everything about the guy I'm not that
much into him but I thought he was an
interesting guy
listen to some of his interviews
and everything he says man [__] just
matches up with my experiences just in
[__] military and fighting and just
how to live and uh you know [__]
there's a certain amount of [__]
Buddhist philosophy type stuff in there
and he's talking about
imagining martial arts that really
didn't have the same rules that they
were used to
and being able to find out to go beyond
certain fighting styles to be free
formed
and try to find what the best way to
fight is to be fluid not really be
constricted in a style
which in those days
that was almost kind of like Outlaw
thinking because you had to fight within
the confines of boxing or
some kind of martial arts match what
he's talking about is something free for
all [__] fighting and this started
this is what sparred on these movies
about like the Kumite and blood Sports
and [__] old [__] old what's his
name what was that guy's name no no no
the guy who [__] said who Bloodsport
was based upon all right [__] what
was his name oh fake uh what's that
fucker's name oh [__]
I'll think I'll remember it yeah
Frank Ducks free Ducks yeah yeah Frank
Ducks Frank Ducks and the Kumite I know
I think of it death matches and death
Sports and [__] which that was [__]
like an unimaginable [__] back in the
[__] 80s 70s and 80s or no that'll
never happen you'll get arrested if you
did anything like that
fought without any rules and
kicked people in the head you know oh
that's too deadly
it's funny because those are kind of
like Macho ties but they were actually
not as Macho as you think they were yeah
you dudes are killing each other on a
football [__] courts
but they their limits they're thinking
it was kind of limited when it came to
fighting Sports
what Bruce Lee was talking about was MMA
it's just the MMA didn't exist then yeah
all right it's a little ahead of us it
was ahead of his time he's talking about
MMA
um the before MMA you had Ultimate
Fighting which when that first appeared
man people were like man is that legal
can you actually do that
and Ultimate Fighting led to MMA
and Bruce Lee was right Bruce Lee was
right MMA is how you fight not Kung Fu
MMA
yeah
now was Bruce Lee as good as he said he
was
yeah
in his time he was [__] fast
up a lot of dudes back in those days
now could you take Bruce Lee and put him
in in an MMA fight no you get his ass
whipped
he's not he's he's too light
but Bruce Lee was talented in his prime
if you would have shown him an MMA match
showed him what the standards were he
went into training and gained weight and
gone it would have done good he would
have done real good in his day he was
good but he wasn't superhuman
you know big dude could pick him up
throw him into a car door just like what
was in that movie so yeah because he was
like really ripped but he was wrong he
was ripped but he only weighed like 140
pounds yeah he was small you know and he
was I think five five or five six he
could move fast but
he didn't have any ground game he didn't
wrestle he didn't [__] know holds and
[__] that but he could have learned that
he was good you know he even though he
was an actor he did practice
um
martial arts type sparring you know and
and the philosophy behind it
so no I give credit to Bruce Lee he was
imagining a coming system we would know
it as MMA
granther says Bunches of hair suits
girls with hairy pits are on streamate
it's a little freaky in a cool way Grand
Theft is getting up in a stream mate I
guess you know what's going to happen is
we're going to be about there streaming
and Grandpa's going to jump in our
[__] screen
come into the stream we've done this in
the streaming like talking to them like
we did a show for them yeah if you see
us in stream mate you can either tell us
who you are or if you want to remain
anonymous that's cool with us it doesn't
matter
yeah don't make it weird it is not weird
we were kind of talking to this person
about that and I was just kind of like
well
I wasn't weirding out though not really
no we're not and matter of fact I
actually thought it was cool because
it's like somebody that and this was
somebody that watches all our shows they
don't comment a lot but they watched all
our shows so they kind of like so we
could like interact with them and talk
to them and [__] like that because to be
honest like a lot of the people that
come up on streamate like they don't you
can't really interact with them very
much like as far as talking you like ask
them questions and they don't answer or
they just like answer with like one or
two words so it's kind of hard to have
like a
conversation with them
so it was kind of cool like that
somebody came on and like knew us
already
so you could like kind of talk to them
already and it may be like a lot more
comfortable I guess
so I wasn't weird at all I actually
really liked it
but you know Nate was talking about how
um
the Matson family and and it was coded
as as the as the Vietcong is that what
he said yeah how did it go read to me
again hey Doug how both Bruce Lee and
the Manson kids at the end are coded as
Vietcong how were they coded as Viet
Cong I don't remember it but I haven't
seen the movie in a while
yeah I don't remember that I don't
remember I don't remember like I said
it's been a while since
probably been like a year all right but
some some people were kind of pissed off
that
that Brad Pitt's character threw Bruce
Lee into the car and [__] it up oh
that would never happen no that did
happen
evidently that did happen uh by people
who were in that scene they were all
partying you know
Hollywood people
um and evidently that did happen that uh
the the guy that Brad Pitt's character
was based on did pick up Bruce Lee and
threw his ass I don't know if it broke
the car door but
he was just a big strong dude and Bruce
is a little guy you know a little
lightweight guy so that's totally
plausible
and they weren't
fighting to the death or anything they
were just playing around you know but
Bruce was good
um
he'd be a lot to handle in his day the
70s were were a time where [__]
fiscal Fitness really wasn't
a priority and people didn't train for
combat type Sports you know the most
common thing would have been boxing
Oriental martial arts were not were
seemed to be were seen to be real
mysterious and otherworldly people
weren't really weren't sure what they
could do
I mean when I was a kid in the 80s you
can ask grampers man we go up to [__]
7-Eleven play video games and look at
Black Belt Magazine and it would make
all kinds of outrageous claims yeah they
believed in like magic it was almost
like mad could a person actually [__]
force their hand through the iron grills
of a [__] manhole cover into a forage
spot
throwing cheese balls and [__] you
weren't quite sure I mean [__] you're
playing [__] Street Fighter and
they're like oh getting [__] just
throwing [__] cheap balls and [__]
you weren't quite sure what was real
and then I had a buddy and they used to
hang out with this [__] gym and Jim
was into [__] the martial arts
[__] I think it was Taekwondo that was
in Taekwondo I remember which one it was
and then my my stepbrother [__]
grandpas remembers him he was a [__]
high-level Taekwondo guy he just beat
people's asses for fun you'd beat like
three dudes asses at once in high school
so we weren't quite sure what was
possible
this is a pre-internet you know it was a
magical time well it's kind of weird
because I kind of feel like in the 70s
and 80s there was this whole weird like
mystery of the Orient yeah yeah type of
thing where it's like you weren't really
sure yeah like all and all of these like
Kung Fu movies and ninja movies like
kind of perpetuated yeah that stereotype
that it's like they almost had like
[__] magical powers ninja might
disappear on your ass
throwing these stars at you that would
kill you're so good at that stuff that
it's like they can do actual magic now
so I kind of and like later on I believe
in yeshida Kim
that's what I mean it was like like he
sold like he sold all those videos tips
to kids yeah is she to Kim of how like a
ninja is gonna sneak into your house by
like you know crouching and like walking
under the window going underneath your
window which only a ninja can do as
everyone knows only it is you could
throw dirt in your face right you know
and disappear because he went around you
you know even though like that's a dance
move dude where'd you go where'd you go
[__] I just did that just now when I
came back from the back yeah
Tom didn't know I was there yeah
[Laughter]
a sheet of Kim
he's selling see I watched that
videotape that's what happened I I took
away some valuable lessons yeah
I give it a little we did a whole
[__] show about that well it wasn't
just about him but
look what oh
what are they talking about now
Ben Ben I'll tell you what if you like
if you liked that movie
Once Upon a Time in Hollywood I got
another one for you
I don't know if you've seen her tonight
you will love this one it's called
the art of self-defense all right it's
it's kung fu movie but it's comedy but
it's also very serious
and it's basically based upon
the same kind of story
of the [__] black dragon fighting
Society
countante very much along the lines of
like count if you know who count Dante
is if you everybody comic books when
you're a little kid they were always
trying to suck back in the 70s they were
trying to sell you count count Dante's
[__]
but that guy was real he was a
hairdresser at a Kung Fu dude
and he has dojo in Chicago and he was in
the Chicago Dojo Wars they were killing
each other
which is [__] ridiculous yeah cause
look people watch Cobra Kai nowadays
yeah this is a great show by the way and
it's like they think that's a little
exaggerated it's not they're basing it
on that they're basically I kind of feel
like they're partially basing it off
or whatever was that the 70s 70s or 80s
count Dante was a uh crazy [__]
who tried to make it in Hollywood they
kicked him out because he was too crazy
uh evidently uh Bruce Lee knew about him
um and he invented the Dem mock which is
like the death touch and he would would
sell you through comic books the secret
to the death touch it's gonna touch you
and he had a dojo
with a bunch of [__] dudes in it
anywhere and fighting other [__]
dudes and other Dojos and [__] they
got attacked by the other guys and
stabbed and killed they [__] had a
whole trial and everything they all got
found not guilty though
because they were defending themselves
but [__] cow Dante made a bomb and
blew up the other guy's Dojo blew the
window out of another guy's nose it's
it's quite a story
well art of self-defense is like uh
based kind of loosely based on a
situation like that a weird ass [__]
karate though Joe
seriously dudes should not be allowed to
do anything ever
because look how it turns out
look at what they always end up doing
it's
it's just yeah he's talking about a
deadliest man alive exactly yeah yeah
deadliest man alive
he says uh he had the black dragon
fighting Society you you could join
through the comics yeah yeah they had
all those Dante got arrested uh uh
trying to Dynamite another [__] Dojo
yeah
he got a pretty elitist yeah
no died he died yeah I thought he did we
did a show well we didn't do a show just
about him but we were talking about he
died mysteriously we talked about him on
our uh bullshito yeah Bushido he died
mysteriously uh probably had something
to do with uh drugs
I don't remember exactly how he died
countdown but uh he I think he was just
found dead died in his sleep or
something he was still young but he was
taking weird drugs and he was [__] he
had a bunch of head injuries and
something happened to him
well obviously yeah something happened
to him he died that's what happened yeah
he had an afro there's a white dude with
an afro and a beard
and um
he was kind of ahead of his time in a
way because he was like uh it was he was
also a guy who kind of was awaiting a
new fighting
[__] platform that ended up being
Ultimate Fighting or
yeah MMA you know that's kind of what
they were they were going towards
he wanted a new way of fighting
martial arts so it wasn't as restrictive
but he was crazy but he was evidently
pretty good he was good good and crazy
those two things aren't mutually
exclusive yeah he's good and he was
crazy Ben says uh quoting countdate
Dante died in his sleep of internal
hemorrhaging yeah caused by a bleeding
ulcer yeah that's right 26 19 that's
right be the ulcer
in his stomach I guess
that's usually where ulcers are well not
always no they could be on your lips but
usually
usually the ones that kill you that
would be or abdominal area I would feel
like yeah and then yeah maybe it's only
in his 30s well he died in 1975. yeah so
he wasn't I think it was that old yeah
which yeah like I said we didn't do a
show just about him specifically but we
did a show called bullshito think about
it we talked about him and ashita Kim
and all those kind of weirdos uh
evidently you know uh Captain Dante's
students outlived him and they loved him
they thought he was great uh they
thought his second uh Dojo was great and
the philosophy behind it
um he was one of the only
um
martial artists that would accept black
students and a lot of his students were
black
and uh that's how they learned kung fu
because the Chinese wouldn't teach it to
anybody but the Chinese and
he was white so he was teaching it to
non-chinese including blacks yeah Ben
said he was only 35 minutes only 35 yeah
yeah he could have been something had he
not died he'd have been something
possible dim mock death
somebody came in and was like yeah okay
now
[Laughter]
is what he called death touch yeah it's
when he could hit you in a way
this very special way in a special place
the special time
where later on eventually you die from
it right from the complications of it
but [__] that's hard to prove isn't it
it is you could well that's the beauty
of it didn't it you could fight some
dude get your ass kicked
four months three years later that dude
and you go got his ass I did that [__] I
touched him I did that I touched him in
the fight I [__] did that [__] and I
did it on purpose three [__] years
that's right got it I did it like yeah
you know the Slow Burn kind of way yeah
yeah ability purposes yeah that's why
that's why you do it like that
um so
so you know Cobra Kai comes out I
watched it it was fun it was a good
series yeah I like Cobra Kai
but there's something about the old
school
my old school
fantasies of [__] Kung Fu they kind
of take me back the way I used to feel
about it
I can't believe that I believe some of
the stuff that I I can't believe I
actually kind of thought maybe that
might work but I like to put myself back
in that earlier time
and and feel what it was like
and really artist self-defense brought
me more back to that
that really did capture that yeah yeah
yeah
it's [__] great one yeah and if you
haven't seen the art of self-defense you
got to see it Terry says 42 years later
he dropped dead yeah right and then back
that damn sneaky niches yeah yeah
I start claiming that now every time
some [__] I don't like dies I
would be like yeah I did that [__] yeah
I just did it in a super sneaky way that
I'm not gonna tell you about and uh it's
top secret yeah I also believe that
ninjas existed
you know and they don't they don't at
least not the way that they're portrayed
in the media no they're not they didn't
even exist the way the Japanese thought
that they existed
a Japanese believed that there were
ninjas did we talk about that on the on
the bolshido show or yeah actually I
think we did a whole show about ninjas
yeah
the Japanese of the 1900s early 1900s
believed in ninjas
but they're misunderstanding what
they're reading
the Shinobi
and Ninjutsu and all that they were just
it just means Special Operations
basically
um
there were no ninjas when you go back
into Japanese history
where
the Shinobi legend or the Shinobi idea
came from were references to
guys in your army setting fire to your
enemies
storehouses
before the battle
that's normal
that's normal [__] uh
battle tanks Battle Tactics yeah that's
all that was they're talking about Scout
Scouts and Recon you know I'm from a
recomplitude but they're talking about
Scouts and reconnaissance type
activities
um which in Japanese feudal Warfare that
was
that was Hardcore [__] but it was
standard back then to do that
over time through the translations of
the Japanese rereading this hundreds of
years later
they're
um
reading into it thinking that armies
hired ninjas
to sabotage their enemies
before the war would happen or before
the battle that's not what that's not
what it says
what they're saying is is that we were
attacked basically where it's coming
from stories like we were attacked by
these guys enemy guys they burned our
[__] up and burned the [__] rice
Storehouse up
uh the uh [__] a week before we got
attacked by the main Army that's just
that's standard [__]
yeah that's not that's energy unusual
right it's you as a general say okay
we're gonna fight these [__] in
a couple weeks well you want them to be
we're gonna weaken them first right go
down there and burn up all their [__]
food yeah and then you take your
hand-picked trusted men to go down there
and go do that
and then they come back okay they'll be
nice and weak next week yeah they're
gonna be hungry next week okay that's
when we'll attack
that's all they're doing
which is just common sense it's just
common sense Battle Tactics that's all
they're talking about and from those
Legends came the idea of Shinobi sure or
or Ninja
next she'll be saying there's no such
thing as Jedis
[Laughter]
I was just thinking about those movies
that they made back in the 80s all this
ninja movies especially those ones that
that [__] one guy makes it
the dude that has the headband that says
Ninja Kawasaki which is the Kawasaki
Ninja motorcycle
yeah yeah
like they bought those and it's like do
they even know like they probably saw
those at a garage sale or something
they're like oh my God it says ninja
right on it yeah we need to get those
yeah and then everybody's like that's a
motorcycle dude like do you know that
and only in America was it called the
Ninja
so maybe they don't know yeah the
Japanese didn't call it the ninja back
in uh in Japan they would they were
We're not gonna call that a ninja be
like us calling it a gangster or
something
how cool would that be if a car was
called like the Ford gang the Ford
gangster four gangsters I'd buy that
yeah it was never called the ninja in in
Japan it's only called that in America
in the United States
it was a market name but um
yeah and then the whole thing about
ninjas wearing black clothes and doing
no no there were no ninjas and what
they're talking about there is that in
Japanese theater
in Kabuki theater
the stage hands were all black against a
black background yes
and in certainly they do that here too
they do it yeah in certain combat scenes
in Japanese
traditional theater
if
if the hero of the story is fighting the
enemy sometimes the enemy is not
portrayed
the enemy is shown is invisible so that
way you just focus on the hero doing the
fighting
on stage
he's swinging and a guy's in a bunch of
damn black suits are holding things up
that he's hitting and [__] dancing
around him and stuff so that evolved
into well ninjas wear black
look he's being attacked by an invisible
force a visible foes ninjas
if you know anything about black
or you have anything about any military
experience black is not camouflaged no
you put on something black and you go
into a [__] wooded area even at night
everybody's gonna see her yeah
what's better is like something like
marpat which is [__] green different
greens Browns and tans
uh just some modeled color
modeled and broken up to break up your
silhouette
so it's more of a pattern than it is
color black will give you a straight
outline you'll see them pretty it's like
well that is clearly the shadow outline
of a man right yeah yeah right but it
looked good on stage sure it says
telling you that the people that made up
the ninja stories didn't have field
experience they saw this on on stage
right I thought it was cool I thought it
looked cool so they're gonna that'd be
the equivalent of seeing on TV they saw
it on TV and put it in it and put it in
and then wrote about it right right and
like it was a real thing like it was a
real thing
but you know we've talked about that
before shit's on TV in in movies it's
not yeah real life most people or their
whole concept of warfare is informed to
them by TV and movies that's not the way
it really is
and no case
well that's kind of true of everything
yeah honestly well because like I said
in fiction
you know certain things work well for
storytelling purposes uh to get people
to watch your movie or your TV show that
um you know I obviously don't have uh
you know I don't have an equivalent in
real life right
so
I don't always they don't always do it
on purpose it's just they're just doing
it for dramatic purposes because like
well if we show this as it really was it
wouldn't look that exciting or you know
what I mean because a lot of things if
you see them in real life like if you
see him in a movie like a shootout or
something like that holy [__] it looks
like super exciting but if you see it in
real life it's really not that exciting
yeah not saying it's not but you know
it's just generally not dude it doesn't
look that cinematic is what I'm saying
that's why I'm saying like dudes have
all these badass fantasies about what a
gunfight's like
look at like security footage or you
know
watch footage from a a helicopter a
police helicopter of police moving in on
a suspect who's fighting the police and
watch how they gun him down
it's not cinematic at all he looks like
a [__] fool yeah it doesn't matter
and from his point of view it probably
seemed pretty cool but it didn't it
didn't look cool on film
yeah you're like a [__] idiot dude
you guys got shot up by nothing over a
[__] expired license plate you idiot
you know it's just it's that stupid
yeah you have to if you're making a
movie about something you have to give
like dramatic yeah you have to give
dramatic heft to the [__] right it can't
just be like realistic [__] where it's
like well I got pulled over for a broken
tail light and then things escalated and
then I got killed well another thing
another thing that civilians are easily
duped by
is that they they think Warfare has is
technological and it isn't not at all
they think well you can never beat us
we're America we got [__] jets that
go mock three and all we have tanks that
can stop this and that
you have to have stuff like us to beat
us no we've been getting our ass kicked
by dudes in flip-flops and sandals and
AK-47s with adiqs we've been getting our
ass whipped by them since the 1960s okay
because War Warfare is not technological
it's about endurance
you know you fought the Vietnamese and
you just killed them and killed them and
killed them but they just never
surrendered
and you didn't make any difference no
matter how many bombs you dropped no
matter what kind of Tanks you put there
it didn't matter
they just persisted and then we left
because you can't do anything
with them that's what I mean it's just
kind of the person that can like take
the most punishment whoever can then out
endure that's all it is it's more of a
that's kind of the truth of the matter
yeah whoever can put up with more [__]
yeah what is the one that's eventually
we had all this technology over Iraq and
Afghanistan they whipped our asses
we left
because they just out endured
well and the thing is well they had more
motivation to do that because like well
we live here yeah that's their house so
it's just kind of like
you know so we're just gonna like
[__] dig in and
you know you're always kind of like
pissing up a rope doing that kind of
crap you can't really enforce your will
on people using these machines
that's not how it works that's why they
wanted mind control so much
with propaganda
man those strawberries are good I
haven't eaten one moonshine strawberries
yeah we still have the strawberry
moonshine that we bought a long time ago
yeah so we're kind of like drinking it
up the strawberries have been soaking in
moonshine for [__] much
yeah this moonshine's been in our fridge
for a long time the thing about it is
that they have
this what brand is this is this um that
Tennessee brand I forgot yeah I can't
remember what it's called but they have
a bunch of different flavors they have
it at our liquor store and it's really
good it comes in a mason jar and
everything
but I will say that it's a little I feel
it's a little overpriced I know it's
very artisan and it's like you know it's
a small I think it's called what is it
called old smokey old smokey old smokey
right yeah so I know they're like a
small company and everything like that
so I'm not going to be Grudge them like
charging but I'm gonna say
that for a mason jar
size
um they range from like 18 to 20 which
is slightly
that's slightly overpriced I feel like
but they do have like a lot of really
good flavors we got this strawberry one
that's good I think the best one we've
got so far was wasn't it
um
was it butter pecan yeah the butter
pecan was the best one oh that butter
but it was weak though yeah but it was
still really good it kind of tasted like
um Bailey's but it's ice cream yeah
um but with a slightly different flavor
but it was kind of along those lines
they're talking about but I noticed that
in the liquor store I was down there the
other day getting some vodka and they
had like a whole rack like by the cash
register and they had a whole bunch of
different flavors yeah they're talking
about camouflage patterns in there hold
on yeah yeah camouflage patterns and my
personal experience and I got a lot of
experience in the field with infantry
units
camouflage patterns only matter when the
camouflage is clean
see when you first go into the field
you're pretty clean the camouflage might
matter but after you've been out there
for a few weeks you're pretty [__]
dirty it doesn't matter what the pattern
was man [__] whatever the mutt color
the mud is that's the color your uniform
is because it starts to [__] kind of
grind into you after a while
so it doesn't have to be camouflaged it
could be solid as long as it's the right
color I found that coyote is good
coyote is a good color
looking Ranger Green or OD greens are
good
with certain kinds of tan depending on
whatever the whatever environment it is
and after a while when you're out out
there for after a few days [__] roll
around into dirt in the mud
it just
the [__] environment just kind of
becomes part of your uniform it becomes
camouflaged anyway
it doesn't you know you
dirt is camouflage because you're gonna
get dirty I mean just like in Predator
you just like [__] roll around in a
mud puddle and you're and you're golden
yeah I like camouflage and Ranger Green
it doesn't have to be a camouflage
pattern just as long as it's a subdued
color
after all that rain and dirt
nevertheless [__] [__] it's it's
gonna it's gonna become camouflage
Tammy says the hubs just brought home a
pint of real moonshine his uncle got a
quart from a friend yeah that stuff is
nasty that's my next one I like the
flavors better
that's that's the next thing I've been
making yogurt yogurt's fun to make just
takes a long time it makes it in the
instant pot makes it in the instant pot
it's good
uh next thing I want to do is I want to
make a still
[Laughter]
[__] or moonshine
it makes it makes them cheap ass vodka
yeah it's legal here in the United
States you you can make all the booze
you want you can't sell it yeah as long
as you don't sell it like if you just
make it for your personal life you can
do it it's all right
but um it's probably that way in most
countries I imagine that you can make it
you just can't sell it because they want
federal tax stamps on the ship
well yeah I get it they want their cut
yeah I'm just saying that it's like but
yeah old smokey my sister told me
she had gone and toured
the old smokey Factory
and she told me that they had a flavor
what'd she say it was it was some kind
of coffee flavor like espresso something
and she said it was really really good
but that's one that I haven't seen
although I have noticed that every time
I go to the liquor store they have more
flavors
so like when I went down there the first
time they had the strawberry they had
pickle
like they had one with like pickles in
it like dill pickles they had the butter
pecan and then they had one other one
that I don't remember what it was but
now they have like a whole rack and I
didn't even see what all the flavors
were so maybe they did have the espresso
one I'm gonna have to look for that next
time but I will say that I don't know if
I can justify paying
like 20 bucks
for a mason jar of it
you know because I mean look for 25.99 I
can get a huge thing of Sky Vodka
so
you know
the moonshine's good I'm not saying that
I'm just saying that it's a little
any and it's and the liquor store that
we have down here down the street which
is just like a dinky little local liquor
store it's the same price as it is at
ABC because at ABC it was
18 19 also Ben the only camouflage that
really [__] matter that I ever saw
was a sniper Ghillie suit
that [__] could be right there
10 15 maybe for me you have a problem
seeing him
because he's been rolling around there's
tree leaves stuck in it and everything
he looks like part of the environment
but just some pattern on a uniform it's
not that effective
if you're far away it just looks like
green anyway if you're close up you can
see him you can see him and the pattern
solid colors just like Ranger Green and
this is probably better to just like
save money on the camouflage and just
like roll around in the money roll
around the mud yeah pretty much well
there was one thing a predator called it
that's what I'm saying well that's why I
thought of Predator well I'm talking
about you know the Predator one yeah
that's what I said they were wearing
marpat pads
BDU pants but they had this coyote
coyote colored jackets Dutch and his
Dutch and Poncho they just wore coyote
colored little shirts it wasn't
camouflage pattern it was just in a
camouflage color
that was good enough and if you were
dirt if you after you've been out there
for a couple days even though they were
only going to be out there I think for
24 hours I think that was the that was
the mission statement
it's not really time enough to get dirty
it takes like [__] three or four days
to get really dirty it just all starts
to come become the color of the
environment
that's good enough
because you camouflage only works at a
distance
doesn't work close up yeah I mean like
if they're right up in your face
right they're right there you're gonna
see them yeah so
like I said it's probably better just to
wear like gray or tan [__] and then just
roll around
or stick some leaves on yourself yeah
you know but military cheaper militaries
use those patterns though with partially
fashion
and parsley it can't hurt
yeah it's true at a distance where it
becomes effective it all looks like one
color anyway they asked me
you know it's green or brown like I said
don't ask me because I can't see [__]
right here so like my vision is going so
bad Tammy says the brand Sugarland
moonshine is good we get ours from
Gatlinburg Tennessee I feel like there's
a lot of good moonshine coming out of
Tennessee these days because I think
that's where old smokey comes from too
yeah I'm just gonna make some moonshine
go for it yeah you're gonna make it in
the instant pot
but still
they got Stills you can get a still off
of [__] Amazon he has been talking
about getting it still for a while I
mean man if you can Brew around vodka
and like save us some money that would
be good yeah she's [__] sugar [__]
potato peels or [__] rice because
damn ways you can do it like we don't
drink a lot a lot but okay but we do
drink a lot so how much vodka do we
usually buy in a week we buy two-fifths
of two we buy two fifths a month more or
less so that's not cheap that's not that
bad 20 something dollars worth that's
not that bad yeah I think it's well I
usually get Skye if I go which is 25.99
so about 50 bucks a month
in vodka yeah
and that's the thing like we drink on
the show
and we've also started drinking on if we
do streamate because that kind of helps
loosen me up you know what I mean so I
usually like have a drink on there too
but
so
uh Tammy says they have what's called
sipping shine and cream flavors Nana
pudding strawberry and creams yeah
I saw Nana time would be all about this
I saw Nana pudding [__] up the store
this brand makes it Yeah well yeah yeah
I don't like bananas so and they have
banana pudding at the Chinese Buffet
they do yeah yeah I haven't tried it
though I told Tom about that I was like
dude yeah
go get some of that [__] like on the
dessert thing I don't like I said I'm
not I don't like bananas and I don't
like banana pudding so
revoke my Southern card that's okay
that's fine I don't really like bananas
but it's well it's not so much that I
don't like bananas like if if there's
any other fruit available I will eat
that over a banana I'll eat a banana if
that's all that's available
but what I particularly hate is anything
that's like banana flavored especially
that like that fake banana flavor oh my
God I hate that so much
I hate that fake banana flavor it's so
gross
but I'm not like a big fan of like
actual bananas either so my grandmother
used to make Nana pudding like all the
time with vanilla wafers and all that
I'd never ate it
never ate it I don't know why and it's
like and the thing about it is that I
you know I was really really picky as a
kid like a picky eater
and I eventually got over that like when
I was in my you know late teens and 20s
I was just kind of like ah [__] it no
it's just now I'll pretty much eat
anything within reason but for and I've
even like started eating some things
that I hated before like I hated
keys I could not [__] say like even
the sight of them made me want to throw
up
but I actually did finally get over that
like largely through Tom making like you
know split police split pea soup and
stuff like that so I kind of got over
that but bananas I just never
I never got into it I'm just not into
banana stuff man I'm just not
well
it's just I'm not I don't hate them I'm
just like not that enthused about banana
flavored things I like a lot of other
fruits I like a lot of other fruit like
I like orange stuff I like pineapples I
like this is what I do this is what I do
watermelon get some rice crispy cereal
with thinly sliced bananas in it that
doesn't sound good either oh it's
[__] great it's not good no I've had
that before I don't like that either I
just I just don't like bananas I just
don't all right I just don't like
bananas okay
you know what I mean I just don't
I just I I don't know I I just don't
like the whole flavor of them yeah there
are a few things like I said I've eaten
a lot of things now that like I wouldn't
have eaten before yeah but bananas I
just I can't get into it I just can't
get into bananas look we've been
streaming for three hours
no we've been streaming for four hours
okay let's go ahead and shut it down
Tammy says I like banana pudding if it's
just made I don't like when the Wafers
get soggy I like it when the wings get
sauce now I like Nilla wafers I'm not
saying that but I I really just don't
like bananas I like them to get kind of
soft I like I like the the the the
Wafers to get soft
I like it both ways though
I mean I would actually take the soft
wafer [__] pudding and then take
fresh Wafers and crush it and put it on
top and then spray some more whipped
cream on it too
you know but look we got to go that
sounds like we've been streamed for book
four hours
well we're having a good time all right
so hopefully you guys have a good it's
almost midnight I well yeah yeah it's 11
30. 11 25 yeah
all right so hopefully you guys have a
good weekend like I said I think what
we're gonna do do you want to do that
this weekend or what what where we'll do
a movie review on Monday instead of
Haunting yeah okay do you want to do
that or yeah
okay
you don't seem enthused one way or the
other that can only answer once I said
okay we'll do that okay all right so
what we'll do is we will do a movie
review I don't know what movie it is
because we haven't watched one yet
um but we'll do it on Monday instead of
Sunday instead of The Haunting show
because I think we're gonna
kind of give the haunting shows a break
for a little while so we'll move the
movie review to Monday so let's do that
so we'll see you guys again on Monday
talking about whatever movie we're going
to talk about which we don't even know
yet so it'll be a surprise for us as
well so hopefully you guys have a good
weekend like I said we might be
streaming on stream eight some of the
times if you want to toddle over there
and see it you may do that and please
talk to us if you show up
so have a good weekend you guys and we
will see you on Monday evening
good night oh Tom said would uh Tammy
said would Tom get pegged while eating
Nana pudding
man man this is gonna she's got like a
whole series of videos planned I need to
write all this [__] down we're gonna
make videos of all of this
all right so we will see you guys again
on Monday for a movie review so good
night and have a good weekend